Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill bird and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
[inaudible]
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking on you.
I hope this isn't too loud.
Hope it doesn't make too much noise.
I'm on the road.
Um,
so you get even even more of the bootleg experience Echo.
For some reason I am in a,
a hotel room that has,
I would say,
Oh,
if I had to guess,
uh,
18 foot ceilings and no,
this is not some super swanky friggin place.
I think it's just an old building and uh,
and people was shorter back then walking around in wool suits.
All,
you know what it was,
they wore hats.
They were big hats back then.
That was it.
That was the deal.
And was like,
probably no one guys,
there's probably no,
whoever had the biggest fancy has hat that the women back then with their hoop
skirts are probably all like,
oh,
he probably guys,
he's probably got all the money.
He's probably got all kinds of money.
Right.
Um,
of course,
you know,
psychologists would probably say that.
It was,
that was all about Dick size.
You know what I mean?
I don't think any guy really thinks about dick size unless he has a little Dick.
Other than that,
if you fucking,
you know,
it's like I'm an average runner.
I never think of,
no,
I actually wasn't.
I was slow and I never even thought about that.
You know what the reality comes down to,
it's not about Dick size.
It's about how much fucking money you make.
You know what I mean?
You meet some broad Nabar.
What does she say?
How big is your Dick?
Yeah,
she doesn't,
she says,
what do you do?
All right.
Are you worth my time tonight?
You know,
and even when she's out there,
they're just trolling for some cock.
You know what I mean?
And she's doing a little fucking checking your feet,
your hands maybe taking a glance down to see how you're hanging.
Right.
If he was some dockers and he was sitting down,
I don't know how the fuck they would tell fry.
Um,
she showed up in the bar and sweatpants.
Yeah.
At some point,
even if she's out there just to get bank,
she is going to ask you what you fucking do.
They can help.
And then I guess part of it is,
you know,
you want to get past the awkward conversation and that is,
what do you do is also like,
you know,
hey,
can you believe this weather and can you believe this weather?
What do you do?
How big is your Dick?
You know,
Bang,
Bang.
And they go right down the thing and then that's when they determine if there's
going to be a white one nightstand.
If they're going to pretend you know that they're not just some size queen and
that that,
you know,
maybe they go and they'll start talking about their family.
You know what I mean?
That's when you know you're fucked.
They started talking about their family.
It's like,
Oh God,
not this.
I hope when you were just going to treat me like a piece of meat,
now you want to have a fucking relationship.
Fuck,
I should've lied about my job.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
As always.
I have no idea what the fuck I'm talking about.
Am I contractually obligated,
even though there's no contract on this podcast,
it's a verbal contract and I honor it.
Okay.
Unlike what happened to Jakey Lee and a bunch of other musicians when they
played with for a certain somebody that everybody thinks is cute.
Oh,
Sharon,
Sharon [inaudible] glad you all remember all that shit.
I went down to fucking Jakey Lee,
Randy Rhodes,
um,
I dunno what you call brown down a rabbit hole.
And then that led me to bring up,
I always read up on that fucking case where the original drummer and bass player
never got played on,
uh,
you know,
was it blizzard of Oz and diary of a madman?
Is it?
Well,
the two albums,
I don't fuck it though.
And they actually asked for the money for paying on those things.
So they fucking,
oh wait.
They ended up buying the rights to the album.
It was fucking in cruises.
I got this,
I got it.
It was a mini series.
It was like the OJ trial,
except with like recording.
So then our,
the Ozzy camp rerecorded the drums in the bass on it.
It's fucking unreal.
Let me,
let me look that shit up.
Let me look that up here as I'm just sitting here babbling.
Um,
but anyways,
Jakey Lee,
what a fucking player.
I know Randy Rhoads is just unreal,
but shaky Lee never,
he never gets teen.
Never gets a fucking shout out.
Okay.
It goes,
it goes from fucking,
you know,
obviously Hendrix,
and then they'll throw some Clapton in there,
then they go to Jimmy page and then boom.
Then it's like Eddie van Halen.
There's like before Eddie and after a,
when it comes to white guys shredders.
And then they always go to Randy Rhodes and then they skip right past it seems
they skip right past Jakey Lee and then they go right to that guy from white
line.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what it is.
No,
cause I've done,
I think they get into the guy,
the fucking speed metal guys.
I have no idea.
All right,
let's see.
Drummer for
blizzard of Oz.
Blizzard of all Aussie.
Uh,
yeah,
Lee Kerslake.
Okay.
Oh by the way,
just let himself go to health.
Christ Almighty.
He looks like he sold tires his whole fucking life.
That's how much stress,
this whole thing
case,
um,
took on the guy.
Okay.
Alright.
After being fired,
wait a minute.
Where are we?
List of Oz.
Osborne band members.
Yeah.
He doesn't even have his own fucking Wikipedia page.
Jesus Christ did Ozzy.
Got Some fucking guitars to what?
Randy Rhodes Jakey Lee.
Zack wild.
Steve Vai.
I don't know if any of these other fucking guys broody size,
size on base.
Come on man.
Okay.
Isn't that crazy?
He had both fucking a bass players surviving bass players from Metallica.
Robert Hilo,
he came in and rerecorded the basis basis where recorded the bass,
I guess.
Jason Newstead,
Tommy Aldridge.
I ran into him and fucking Belgium freaked him out cause I was freaking out
and then I didn't ask for a picture.
He looked relieved.
I was just like,
sorry man.
Thank you for all the great music you've,
you've given me.
I really appreciate it.
He goes,
all right,
cool.
And that was it.
All right,
I'm going to get off this fucking subject.
I'm sorry.
Um,
anyways,
I'm in Saint Petersburg,
Florida.
Tomorrow night.
However,
tonight I am in Tampa to see bump bump,
bump on
[inaudible].
Yeah,
I'm going to see the Patriots play at,
uh,
at Joe Robbie Stadium.
Whatever the fuck they call it up here.
Um,
Donovan Smith.
Fucking memorial stadium.
I don't want you to call it Tampa.
The fucking
okay.
Pirates of the Caribbean stadium.
What the fuck is the name of it that actually has a regular name?
The fuck is Tampa.
God Damn fucking Tampa football stadium.
I know it.
I know this fucking name.
But anyways,
this is the last one I have to go to.
There we go.
Football Stadium.
Come on,
come on.
What's it?
Raymond James Raymond James Stadium.
Um,
this is the last,
uh,
the 32 professional football teams that I need to see a home game of a,
this will be the 34th one that I've been to.
Cause I went to St Louis Rams and also the San Diego chargers and then they both
moved to La and I went to those games because I,
cause I have a problem.
Um,
so I'm looking for,
this is going to be fucking awesome.
Thursday night football,
they're going to get out there and they're under roos wearing all the same
colored fucking clothes.
Now that the Patriots go was blue rather than red.
Um,
the red on red,
Jesus Christ is just,
I don't know,
somebody's going to have to wear it cause I think that a,
but maybe Tampa,
we'll go with the gray.
I don't know guys.
I think that they should have a fashion runway to start it.
Um,
so of course the big,
the big question you gotta ask 'em you know,
I'm always into fucking,
uh,
I'm a content,
you know what I mean?
So I don't give a fuck about the wide receivers.
I don't give a shit a bunch of quarterbacks.
Your running back,
what's going on at the offensive line for Christ's sake,
if he can't defend you fucking quarterback and you can't fucking blow open some
God damn holes,
you're not going to make any passes of running again.
I'll tell you right now,
you're not going to go 80 yards in this fucking week.
I gotta be quiet cause this thing is echoing.
So have loud here.
Um,
so what does it come down to?
The,
the fucking diva.
The offensive line.
All right.
They'll rock star the one that makes all the fucking money.
Nobody cares about the fucking guards.
Nobody gives a shit about the center.
Nobody gives a fuck about the right tackle.
It's all about the left tackle in the NFL,
protecting the blind side.
Unless you have a lefty,
unless she have a lefty.
How many lefty NFL fucking quarterbacks are there?
And how pissed is the left tackle on that fucking line?
You know,
he finally gets his name,
shouted out the naked soldier,
right?
Cause that he say themed naked soldier.
He's only been with us for fucking ever.
They just never say his name,
cause he rarely fucks up.
Donovan Smith,
I see you met new thing.
No one the left tackles no one who's making the money up there on the offensive
line.
So according to the scouting report,
Donovan Smith,
a Penn State guy,
Penn state guys,
always,
always solid football players.
Just a great program up there when they're not up there touching kids,
they just do wonderful things.
Wonderful Goddamn things,
you know,
and they're not snapping towels and unsuspecting eight year olds,
sorry,
Penn state,
you fucking earned it.
All right.
And you know good.
And God damn well,
despite what happened up there,
you still want to see the Joe Pa statute come back.
And what does that,
what does that say about you?
Um,
what does that say about statues?
What is,
you know what I do love about,
you know,
Penn state and it's not the molestation of children.
What I love,
you're going to get it.
This civic,
I'm going to give the Catholic church shit.
I got to give it to you too.
You know what I mean?
Penn state football program was like the Catholic Church fucking slide up.
Like the Catholic churches,
like the Big Burger with the bacon on it when it comes to fucking rape in kids.
And uh,
but you know,
just sheer number,
you know,
if you looked at,
at,
at molested kids,
like you were counting calories,
all right there definitely that Wendy's triple cheeseburger,
the Catholic churches where Penn state is just,
that's,
you know,
little sliders.
I'm just going to have,
I'm just going to nibble.
I told myself I've been doing so great at the gym.
I could cheat tonight,
but I'm check's going to fucking nibble.
Um,
what I do love about the Penn State,
uh,
and I realize it wasn't everybody up there who is raping children.
Okay.
Now that's when you know,
you've,
I know that's when you know,
your program is in trouble.
When in order to defend it you have to say,
hey,
not everybody was up there raping kids.
Bump.
Um,
all right.
I just liked that they have the basic simple fucking uniforms.
Okay.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
the first time I saw those Oregon ducks,
those crazy uniforms,
I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then after a while I kinda liked him like,
Eh,
you know,
it's Kinda cool,
whatever.
But now it's just become a fucking fashion show and there's a bunch of Shitty
fucking football programs out there.
You know what I'm talking about?
University of Illinois,
where the fuck do you get off with that disco ball in your head?
Like you've never even sniffed a big 10 championship since we were even in
fucking Vietnam.
Let's look that up right now.
Let's look that up right fucking now.
When was the last time that basketball school won a big time?
Big 10 champ championship.
I can't fucking talk.
All right.
University of Indiana's,
I suppose I saying Illinois.
Sorry,
Indiana.
Um,
last big 10 football.
I guarantee you we were in covered covered wagons here.
Football Championship.
Okay.
I guarantee you the starting 11 were all white guys.
Indiana.
Who's your football?
Here we go.
This ought to be a quick Wikipedia page.
All right.
Um,
why am I picking on these guys?
All right.
Location,
conference,
bowl,
record three and eight.
Conference titles.
Two,
they won one in 1945.
Baba Dopa.
[inaudible] we won the war.
Let's all make kids.
Let's all cure diseases.
Then we'll have a bunch of hurricanes cause with throwing plastic in the ocean.
I'm 1967 because
I will not seek,
nor will I accept a second term as your prayer.
Who the fuck does
LBJ Sing?
And Sunshiny Life,
Huh?
Who should be is more importantly probably the question.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm going to the fucking game tonight.
Uh,
look for
Jameson Winston to have a career day because our defense is like the make a wish
foundation opposing quarterback.
What is your dream?
Gee,
I've always wanted to throw for 400 yards.
No problem.
Not only are we gonna make that happen,
we're going to do it in the first half.
[inaudible] all right,
go fuck yourself now.
I just trashed my own team before you guys all get all butthurt no fucking pun
intended.
All right about me.
Making fun of your Goddamn team.
Donovan Smith is the left tackle
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
He is from Penn state.
He is evidently according to the one scouting report that I looked up,
has yet to live up to his potential
quick footed,
very athletic for his size,
has great hands,
but has yet to live up to his potential.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but if it is,
then I am going to,
I want to nominate him for the delight.
Howard,
not the white.
The white white people do White Howard,
not white.
Dwight Black Dwight Dwight.
All right,
Howard.
Given the Dwight Howard award,
every time you look at Dwight Howard,
you gotta be thinking,
what the fuck is wrong with that guy?
That guy is like,
he's like a fucking superhero.
Okay.
He's so God damn big.
It's so strong.
It's like,
why don't you just steal one move from Kevin Mchale two from a chemo lodge one
and just dominate the fucking league.
I don't know what he does all day.
He looks like he does curls and goes to the barber shop.
Yeah,
hair is always perfect.
He's always fucking shredded,
but he just like,
there's no fire in the man's game,
you know,
you know when you go and get play pickup hoop,
right.
Mike,
I've done that.
And this decade I haven't played,
I can't remember the last time I play pickup.
Who put the fucking worst was,
well,
if you got that little fella garden,
you're on defense.
You know what I mean?
And you'd fuck it.
Fucking guy was just all over you.
You know what I mean?
His fucking junk was right on your leg.
It's like,
I get it.
You're taking this seriously where you get the fuck off me and you're up full
court fucking press.
It's like,
buddy,
we're just out here to fucking burn off some calories.
You know,
we all ate a Caesar Salad and then just figured out the dressing.
It was like eating a fucking burger.
Can you just,
can you let me just run to the fucking half court line?
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I don't know what the fuck is going on with our defense.
Um,
I have no idea.
As I mentioned,
as I mentioned on our last podcast,
our safeties
and and in our corner,
one of our corners,
they've all played with each other for fucking years.
And the only thing the new guys is Stefan Gilmore and I,
I can't imagine that the entire defense is going to shit because of one fucking
cornerback.
I left the watch tonight sitting up high.
What does he play?
Does he play on the right side of the defense?
I don't know.
All I know is Tampa doesn't have any fucking sacks for this year.
I kept looking up.
There's no fucking way.
They have no sex when in October they have no sex.
Okay.
You don't,
I I they protesting.
Um,
I dunno what violence against fucking white quarterbacks.
You never know what the NFL,
it's always about a co,
uh,
cause they finally got rid of the pink.
Now it's still mystic violence awareness month as if nobody aware that there was
domestic violence.
You know,
I'll tell you what's fucked up is anytime professional football player beats his
wife,
it becomes a national fucking news.
Okay.
Yet a plumber can slap his wife around.
Threw a fucking 25 30 year marriage and you're never going to hear about it on
ESPN,
are Ya?
No,
you are not.
And what are they going to do?
They're going to create this false fucking image that athletes are the only ones
out there who occasionally flip out when there's ranch dressing rather than blue
cheese for their buffalo wings.
Right?
Okay.
God forbid if an athlete does something,
it's all over the fucking news.
But if an accountant,
okay,
accountant fucking starts shaking his wife a little bit too much in an apple.
Bese you know,
does ESPN,
do they cover that?
Okay.
Does the NFL suspend that account?
No,
they do not.
So I want to ask you,
how much does ESPN,
how much does the NFL truly care until they start covering the domestic violence
done by all men comedians too.
I'll tell you right now,
I put my wife in a triangle right before I went on the road.
Okay?
I said,
this house is going to be clean when I get home.
Um,
this isn't a funny topic.
This should not be joked about.
I'm now going to fucking grand stand about it as I wear clothes that were made
in a sweatshop
because I care.
I got my wife with a good one yesterday.
Um,
I texted her,
uh,
hey,
when I get back to town,
I'm going to take you to Barney's.
You know,
it's this fancy clothing place,
right?
That I never heard about until there was a woman in my life.
And that is,
that is a 100% truth.
And then they turn around and they wonder why every once in a while they catch
your backhand.
We're taking collars.
Um,
I uh,
yeah,
it's a fancy place.
This clothing store called Barneys.
So I text her,
you know,
cause now that I have the little one,
my little boo bear,
um,
the level of guilt that I have when I go on the fucking road.
I mean,
I gotta to ask other parents like,
when do you hit the ceiling of the love that you feel for your kid?
It's like every day.
It just,
it just keeps,
you know what I mean?
It's like a,
it's like Wah,
you know,
I don't watch game of Thrones,
but like every year when the new season comes out,
like the fucking excitement gets higher.
And I always think,
well,
at some point it's got to level off and it's not happening.
So like if you've never had a kid coming home to your kid is the same level of
excitement of these nerds on Twitter when a new season of game of Thrones comes
out.
Okay.
The same falsetto excitement goes into your voice.
It's unbelievable.
Um,
so I have a tremendous amount of guilt,
uh,
when I leave now,
but I mean,
everybody's got to eat.
So I gotta you know,
I mean,
a plumber keeps plumbing is sinks.
Right?
Um,
so,
um,
okay,
what the fuck was my point
coming home?
Oh yeah.
So I have all this guilt.
So,
um,
I texted Nia,
I said,
hey Neil,
when I get home,
when I get back,
I'm taking it to Barney's.
And she goes,
she's like,
oh my God,
explanation.
At some point she goes,
yes,
really?
And then I text back beanery
Oh,
I got it.
The good one.
And she's such a hot shit.
She fucking laughed.
RSF Barney's beanery by the way,
is a a,
isn't isn't a an La eatery out here where they give you a completely
irresponsible level of food when you go in there.
[inaudible] irresponsible if you cared about human life,
a heroic portion of food,
if you're truly informed and concerned about the environmental issues that are
about to hit us.
Last week I was writing for hurricane monthly
and if you look up that article recently,
I want a doctorate at uh,
at Massasoit community college and now I feel I know things.
So of course now I'm going to have people refer to me as a doctor for the rest
of my life.
Like bill Cosby did bill,
cause we always do that.
Dr Bill Cosby.
It's like,
dude,
you got an honorary degree.
Unless I'm out of my fucking mind,
I shouldn't have said his name.
Speaking of Penn state.
Oh Geez.
It's spelled Jesus.
Jesus.
Yeah,
everybody's just getting trashed on this one.
Well,
you know what,
I'm a little grumpy.
Okay.
I took a fucking rent out.
You know,
it was funny.
I'm sitting there saying I miss my kid,
but I'm still a selfish cut and came out here a day early to go to a football
game to,
to fucking well,
you know what?
I still act out my hobbies.
I'm a big believer in that.
You gotta be a little selfish.
Still's a debt.
All right,
Bill,
Talk Yourself off the guilt ledge.
Give yourself the free fucking pass here.
No,
you still have to have you fucking hobby.
Um,
you know something to look forward to when the,
when your kid,
you're fucking bundle of joy finally falls asleep.
You know what I mean?
Everybody goes,
Hey,
when your kids sleeps you sleep.
You know what I say?
I say fuck that.
You go out in the garage,
you play a couple of paradiddles.
All right?
You go on the Internet and you learn how to fly a crazy train.
That's what you do,
okay?
You don't sleep before sleep is for liberals that care about other air quote
care about other people,
okay?
If you look at conservative people,
those people never sleep,
okay?
Cause they don't like anybody and they just sit there staring out their fucking
window.
Even if they have a conservative next door neighbor,
they do not trust them.
Okay.
Cause they are,
they are type A,
can you be a type a liberal?
I don't know what type A is type A is fucking annoying.
You know what I mean?
That's basically what it is.
Type based the kind of person that needs a fucking entourage.
Right.
Type A's,
the kind of person that goes through the security line at the airport.
Right.
And when he goes,
gets to the other side,
takes all his fucking shit out and doesn't fucking get,
has been out of the fucking way.
He doesn't give a shit.
It's all about him.
You know,
if you broke,
if you did like a fucking,
uh,
an airport security combine,
okay.
And you watched me go through,
rather than running the 40 yard deaths,
it's,
you get in,
you're getting ready to get,
you have all your shit off and your fucking laptop out.
Okay.
I would test off the fucking charts.
Of course.
I'll always be the slow fucking white dude that I am,
but when I get to the other fucking side,
all right,
well when I get to the other side,
after I'd been fucking slowly cooked in that little microwave that they sticky
in,
which you know,
something I've actually just given into at this point,
if they want to slowly kill me,
I say good.
I say good for them.
You know,
why?
Because we're overpopulated and who am I to say that I should still be here?
Lead the lizard people fucking kill everybody and start over again with the
robots.
We're taking calls.
Um,
so I get through when I get on the other side.
That's when Bill Belichick's gonna draft me when everybody else looks past me.
Okay.
With my Bunker Hill community college educational background,
just given all kinds of community colleges shouts out from Massachusetts.
Shout outs this week,
this Thursday.
Um,
this is when
bill Belicheck,
we finally smiled like the Grinch at the end of the Grinch stole Christmas is
when he saw me fucking not only get my fucking bins,
I grabbed everybody else's bins
and
Mumble,
come on people loud enough for people to hear,
but not loud enough for anyone to address me,
right?
Okay.
And he sees that I lead by example,
but the,
the level of judging that I do when I go through the fucking airport security
line,
and when you fucking take your shit out of the band and you just fucking leave
it there,
I'm like,
you are a selfish fucking cunt.
You're a terrible mother.
You're a terrible father.
You're a terrible fucking person.
Okay?
And if I was as blessed is that fat fucking North Korea to be running everything
and stealing all the ham,
keeping it all from myself,
right?
He gets a haircut every day.
That's selfish.
Fuck,
okay.
There's all these people are fucking starving probably because of the economic
stank shanks and sanctions that the free world has placed upon him.
And he's like,
fuck that.
I'm the leader.
I get all the pork chops.
I need to stay clear between my big butcher block fucking head.
All right.
I need to stay clear to know when it is,
when it's time,
because we're dealing with the loo.
I want to how scared they are of Trump.
It's just kind of fun.
This is like we're matching crazy homeless guy to crazy homeless guy.
I remember that.
Those things bumfights that's what's going on at the fucking political level.
This is a bum fight.
Alright.
Don't let the uniform in the fucking suit,
which a lot of people will say is a uniform.
A lot of people in the liberal arts major of a college will say that it is a,
that it is a uniform,
that it is a boys club.
Okay.
That it is a system that needs to be shut down and they'll say this as they
don't wear a fucking Bra.
What the Ted swinging two and fucking fro as if they're making a statement.
I love that thing that women want to do,
like the people who,
the women that are rejecting bras.
It's just,
this is some sort of restricted thing.
It's like,
Hey,
we were doing you a favor.
We already stair your titties enough.
If you want to walk around with the nipple sticking out of your fucking shirt,
if you ever think that that's going to get fucking old on our side of the fence,
I say,
you remove your bras and you room,
you remove them.
Now,
um,
you know I should do more podcasts with 50 foot ceilings.
I think my ego just it.
There's finally enough space in a room for my fucking head.
I'm excited.
I'm going to a football game tonight.
My last one,
my last one that I have to go to and I've been to all the baseball,
all of the football.
Who the fuck can say that?
You think I'm going to stop there?
I'm not.
I'm going to see all the hockey and all the basketball.
You think I'm going to stop there?
I'm not.
I went to the Daytona 500 I'm going to Talladega next year.
I've been to the Kentucky Derby.
I don't give it this.
I'm doing the fucking road.
I'm going to every breads circus.
So put your fucking thoughts on hold sporting event that this great nation has.
And when I'm done here,
I'm going overseas.
Thank you.
Do think I'm fucking above going to a cricket match.
Okay.
Arguably the greatest drinking game ever,
ever created.
If you go to a traditional one,
it takes a fucking week to play.
You can literally go on a week long fucking bender and your wife can't say
anything.
It's like what honey?
I told you I was going to the game.
Am Am I allowed to have a little bit of fun life?
Um,
NHL starts tonight.
[inaudible] um,
and I believe I heard through the grapevine that ESPN guts the Formula One
contract for next year.
So ESPN,
could you do me a favor?
Can you please not apply your progressive formula?
Whatever the fuck it is that you're doing.
I know you've taken on water over there because everybody's watching sports on
the app,
but can you please,
can you please keep Formula One,
the international gym that it is?
Can you please not replace everybody and get a bunch of Americans in there,
right.
One from each race like they do on the MTV w real world.
And then you have a woman running it,
whatever it is.
And then in the end you feel good about yourselves before you go back to your
white,
your whites only gated community.
I'm fucking with you.
I don't give a shit.
Just,
I don't give a fuck if it's all women.
I don't give a fuck if everybody's healing helion.
However you say Kenya Chess,
get somebody out there that knows what the fuck they're talking about and can
deliver their points without screaming movie quotes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Can you do that?
Can you do that without going around the horn and having some fucking goddamn
air raid siren going off for fucking every 20 minutes?
Yeah,
that fucking show.
If anybody can explain to me how points are earned and lost on that show,
uh,
I swear to God you should be running this nation.
Okay.
All right.
Ah,
you,
why you guys listening?
This is just the ramblings of a crabby old man.
I'll tell you,
you know something that I don't understand.
I don't understand why the Internet every fucking day has to tell me that this
is the greatest fucking thing that I'm ever going to see.
And I also don't understand why I'm so fucking stupid.
Like a moth flying towards a fucking bright light in the middle of the night.
I always click on it and it,
oh,
it always underwhelms me
like the Shannon sharp thing this week.
What the fuck was so fucking amazing about that?
I'm on that and mild in that hand dog and everybody,
like the one that I clicked on was,
and it was at this moment that Shannon sharp became the president of the United
States.
He's putting a cheap cigar in his mouth,
making a reference to the boozy lakes.
That's the greatest thing that ever happened.
I mean,
I,
I guess,
I don't know.
You're telling me you're telling me like that that's better than,
than
[inaudible].
When Ozzie played live
on that fucking TV show,
it looks like a basic cable show and he came out with a track suit that said
Ozzie on it in case he forgot what his fucking name was.
And he had Rudy SARS,
O on Bass,
Randy Rhodes on guitar and fucking Tommy Aldridge on drums.
And you see,
you see like Ozzie literally turning around in awe of his own fucking band.
You're telling me
that a guy taking a Dutch master and he we want to get,
if he had the fucking bottle of booze right there,
you know what it is built.
It's just young people having fun and you're taking it literally and you know
what you're doing.
You're doing what you said you always weren't going to do,
which is you.
You were not going to hang around young people.
You,
you knew that your time had come and gone and you're going to let them have
their fucking fun.
You know what?
So I apologize.
You guys are absolutely right.
That was the greatest thing that ever happened and he should be the next wall.
I mean the next leader,
that'd be actually a great fucking thing.
If you had him as leader and then he was communicating with that guy in North
Korea,
then the guy in North Korea could not get mad because he could not understand
what the fuck Shannon sharp's talking about.
Do you remember in World War II when we had like native Americans speaking in a
communicate and shit and the Japanese couldn't crack it yet?
Shannon sharp is the modern day version of that.
I'll never understand it.
I don't want us to,
because I could understand every fucking word that he said as a pro.
He was fucking hilarious,
you know,
sending the Patriot missiles and all that.
The second he became a commentator,
I don't know what happened.
I'm all right,
Lou crate,
so he stuck his tongue in a fucking beehive.
All right,
Luke crate be the envy.
Give me the loop.
Be The envy of your friends and get 100% exclusive
crates@lootcrate.com slash burr and enter my code bird to save $3 off on any new
subscriptions.
The nerve of me saying that Shannon is difficult to understand when I can't even
fucking read out loud.
October's loot crate theme is mythical.
Luke crate offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical fashionista than try loot where all of this shit's
going to end in an ocean someday and in at least develop a tropical storm
monthly wearables and accessories with cold classics and your favorite
franchises.
If you want to get fancy,
if you want to get a bigger box with even bigger loop with Lou crate dx a,
you hear the stories,
the whispers of creatures and beings beyond your imagination.
I go every time.
I think it's a phrase,
it's a fucking sentence.
I don't even know what I'm saying here.
You hear the stories,
the whispers of creatures and beings beyond imaginations.
You hear that in the trunk,
but you hear that in your head sums going on because I fuck this reed up every
time and they continue to advertise with me,
so that must mean that I have a bunch of people are into this shit.
Join us as we peer into the shadows and look into the other realms for October's
truly mythical collection.
Get unreal items from marvel,
Ghostbusters,
stranger things,
and Buffy the vampire slayer.
One lucky subscriber will also win a mega crate of seriously epic proportions.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific time to subscribe and receive that
months crate and when the cutoff happens that it,
that's it.
It's all go to Luke,
Luke,
crate.com/ [inaudible] and enter my code burr to save $3 off on any new
subscription today.
I have no idea.
I mean they could,
they could literally write that in Spanish and I would fucking understand it
just as much as what I just said there thoughtfully.
Everybody me out,
everyone at some point has wished they could have have beer,
wine or liquor delivered.
Oh,
absolutely.
Absolute fucking Lily.
We have,
well,
someone finally decided to do something about it.
I love it and I loved the John Wade vibe of this copy.
Um,
okay.
Next please mention all of the talking points below.
Well just write them and I'll read them.
Introducing thoughtfully the alcohol delivery app,
saucy delivers your favorite wine,
beer and liquor,
right to your door on demand.
You know,
I watched this fucking twilight zone,
um,
the twilight zone of what's it called,
16 millimeter prison or whatever.
And it was about this aging ingenue.
She used to be this big star in the 1930s and she couldn't handle the fact that
she wasn't young anymore.
So she just sat in her mansion in this dark room watching all of her old movies,
drinking booze.
And as I watched it,
I was like,
I would love to fucking do that.
What'd you just love to take a decade off from your life?
You can just watch old home movies of back when you were sober,
you know,
to get out of bed without making noises and shit.
Ah,
right.
And just sit there and you know,
there is some to be said about drinking yourself to death,
you know,
as long as you can walk around like a nice fancy evening gown with a train like
she had,
you know,
just be all thoughts.
All right,
we're back to the copy now.
If you live in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego,
or Sacramento,
your thoughts,
the order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less,
ready to drink.
For the rest of us thought the we'll deliver beer,
wine,
and liquor to your door in two days or less.
Nationwide.
There are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
If you,
if you've got the saucy app,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the saucy app and enter the Promo Code [inaudible].
That's the saucy app,
spelled F,
a u s e,
y and enter Promo code bar for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today and use Promo Code Berg.
Oh Shit.
[inaudible]
club looking good.
Doesn't need to cost a fortune five folk is revolutionizing the way men shop at
five four club.
I've never had copy that says it's fucking name more than these people.
They found a way to make looking great,
great looking clothes affordable for everyone.
Five four club also understands that your time is extremely valuable.
Why wasted?
At the mall or wandering around stores when he can sit at home and have saucy
delivery.
Your bows,
you can order that evening gown with the train with fat folklore five phone
motherfucker each month they send you a curated box of two to three items that
are handpicked to match the current season and your style.
Five foe club partners,
what defense you run into?
Three.
Four?
No,
the [inaudible] five forward with two fucking safeties is that the cover to um,
partners with um,
cutting edge designs and brands.
So you'll get the same quality as top designer clothes for way less.
They've been to helping men with fashion for over 15 years and shipped to
100,000 men every month.
Chris Paul and Mark Walberg use five folk club and five foe is featuring
featured in GQ,
vice and in style among other applications.
This is like a fucking actor or an athlete that's completely lost their mind and
speaks about themselves in the third person.
This is fucking ridiculous.
There's still another half a paragraph.
Let's count how many times they say that their name again.
They know what they're doing.
So if you don't,
that's okay.
Five fold.
That's one club will help you build your wardrobe one month at a time because
when you look good,
you feel good.
It's a fact of life.
It's also a cliche.
You don't need to say that you get $120 worth of clothes for just $60 a month.
That's half off.
You can pause or cancel any time,
no commitments,
and as a fivefold club,
that's two member,
you receive up to 50% off items in their online shop and access to exclusive
members only,
not the jacket items.
Free shipping in size
exchanges,
sorry,
go to five four club,
three
europe.com right now and enter Promo code and they'll give you 50% off your
first month's package plus a free pair of sunglasses.
That's 50% off your first package at five four club,
spelled F I e f o u r.com.
That's four times plus spelling.
That's five Promo Code five four club.
That's five promo-code Burger.
All right,
frank bridge,
everybody.
Thank God this is the last one.
Frame Bridge.
Frame.
Bridge is the easiest way to custom your weighted custom frame,
your favorite art and photos without ever leaving your house.
You know,
there's a fine line between being that person that has in their life and then
like you have way too many fucking photos on your fucking wall.
And it's like,
is this person stalking somebody?
You know what I mean?
So when you use frame bridge,
make sure there's enough up there of your dog and you know,
whatever fucking landscapes of some shit don't have like 58 of just family
members.
All right?
That's fucking weird.
Your family members are not Framus.
Nobody gives a shit.
Uh,
with our simple online ordering process,
you can order a fully customized piece in minutes.
Here's how it not.
If you're me,
take me a fucking hour.
Here's how it works.
Go to Frame bridge.com upload your photo from your computer or directly from an
Instagram feed.
And if it's silly enough,
we'll share it with the rest of the Internet and it'll become a meme and you'll
never get to leave your house again.
Then you can go to Saucy,
order your fucking booze in five four club to Audi and new pajamas.
Look at that,
that's called,
that's called an advertising call back.
Or if you have the physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get help from their talented designer.
The expert team at frame bridge will custom frame your item and 10 days,
not weeks or month to deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang the best part instead of hundreds,
you pay at a framing store.
Their prices start at $39 all shipping is free.
My a plus.
My listeners get 15% off their first order frame,
bridge.com when they use my code Burr,
give your personal experience using frame bridge.com the site,
the ease of order,
how your piece turned out and how easy and affordable it was.
Get started today.
Framing your photos are our go to frame bridge.com and use the Promo code
[inaudible].
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order frame.
bridge.com/berg Oh frame bridge.com code bar.
That's what it's not.
Slash bar code bar.
You know furs?
He's fucking hilarious.
Fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
Oh,
the Oh,
he's right.
My fault.
He okay.
I thought he was getting in at fucking six o'clock in the,
in the game.
Was It fucking seven?
I was like,
you're going to go straight to the game.
All right.
Uh,
hang on a second.
My fault.
I thought the game was at seven.
All right.
Now I got him all fucking nervous.
All right,
that's it.
I'm good.
I got time to do my first elliptical.
Now that I fucking,
oh,
did I tell you guys I got my first MRI.
I got one on my shoulder and then I got one on my calf to make sure I don't have
any blood clots from whatever the fuck I did to my leg.
You know what I mean?
They didn't want to stroke out while I was doing fucking jumping jacks.
Um,
so anyways,
Jesus Christ,
it's fucking hilarious.
You go in there and sometimes they let you use headphones from what I've heard.
But my place that I went to,
which by the way was fucking hilarious.
I'll walk and the chick behind the desk is all tatted up and I'm like,
like to the point,
it's like,
do you play in a band?
If you don't,
you should.
She look like a rock star,
but she's wearing scrubs.
You know,
that should've been my first red flag.
Like what kind of fucking medical places is,
I mean she was Cooley Shit.
But I'm just saying,
you know,
so then I go down there and when I get out it's cash only.
The second business is cash only and there's not a bunch of of Italians running
it.
I'm like,
all right,
what the fuck is going on here?
There's something about Italians cash only.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it's like,
oh,
that piece of America that's now gone.
It's actually quaint,
but everybody else,
I'm like,
what kind of fucking funny shit is going on here?
Um,
all right,
so that's the podcast here.
Oh,
look at that.
I'll give you 45 minutes on a Thursday.
Um,
that's it.
Oh,
Billy.
No Fun.
49 days.
No Busan,
no fucking Busan.
Um,
oh Geez.
I gotta take this call.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
Your cons and I'll,
uh,
I'll talk to you on Monday there.
She's
out of town at
[inaudible] college.
Beulah rat with dominion and boas on it.
Indiana nine
[inaudible] down here.
The AGTS to the board's way was more than they'd seen.
I was in
[inaudible]
Ah,
wife's family.
The secret upstairs.
Alright.
Hey,
bill loved the podcast and all the bullshit.
So I've been dating this lady who I completely love,
can't get enough of her.
We've been going out for a solid two years now.
Good for you.
Um,
there has always been a rule at her house.
She lives with their parents because she's in a program in order to become a vet
tech.
So money's tight for her that I am not allowed to go upstairs ever.
All right.
Being a guy,
I have no problem with this.
A,
I'll bender over the pool table and her f Jesus Christ.
Dude,
whenever this,
this took a left turn,
I'll bender over the pool table.
Her father built because fuck it.
If you try to stop me from banging her in the bed,
I'll just find another way.
All right,
do what?
What did that have to do with what you're talking about?
You got me all interested in,
why can't you go upstairs?
Like there's this big mystery.
Now all of a sudden you're like,
well,
final vendor over the fucking hot water heater downstairs.
You can't stop me.
All right,
I am hoping you're going to get back on track here.
That was like a weird beat,
a B story.
Um,
he goes,
so I finally get annoyed at this whole no upstairs policy and decide to do a
little investigating.
Well,
aren't you just a nosy little conti?
Did you finally get annoyed of the rules of a house that isn't yours?
You know what,
sir?
So this far into your email,
I don't like you.
I don't like that whole shit.
We at Deere,
you haven't your disrespect in her father and Santa Mom.
I'm gonna Fuck your daughter over the pool table that you built.
All right.
That's supposed to be internal monologue.
You're not supposed to share that with others
anyways.
Uh,
no one in the house at this point,
by the way.
Oh,
there's no one in the house.
Why can't you guys help me out?
You know I suck at reading.
He,
okay.
There's no one in the house at this point,
by the way.
I work third shift,
so they leave me the fuck alone.
Between 8:00 AM to 3:00 PM I went upstage upstairs and I find a garbage in the
hallway.
Every room is filled with junk and there's only one way to enter it.
This is every room,
her parents' room,
hers,
the office.
It's all a complete nightmare.
Just waiting for TLC to show up.
I'm now giving you that.
How can I approach this ordeal with her?
I love her to death and she may be moving in with me sometime between the next
few months.
This shit is not going to fly with me,
but I know that if a resident gets that bad that there is something wrong with
them.
Mentally.
She has always been messy.
But then again,
I'm a fucking cop who doesn't have time to clean up my place.
So maybe this is the calm before the storm with this chick.
Um,
yeah,
that's really fucked up now.
All right,
well you know something.
You're already broke the seal.
This is what I would do.
This is so fucking creepy.
If she,
if you really want to make it,
go with this girl,
I guess.
I guess I would go back up there again
and I into her room and just have a look around and look like if that's some
parent shit or if that's her shit.
You know what I mean?
Um,
and if it's her shit,
I would be,
uh,
ah.
Jesus is fucking brutal.
The thing,
you know what the big thing is,
is the fact that the downstairs is immaculate,
so they're there.
They're only halfway down the rabbit hole.
Um,
I dunno,
Dude.
You know what?
This is your tree.
You're fucking sitting in it.
I don't that there's no way to bring up that you went upstairs without just
saying I went upstairs.
Yeah.
What are you going to say?
Well,
the bath,
the ice is what years is what you do.
This is what you do.
You clog up the bathroom downstairs.
All right?
Just clog up the fucking toilet downstairs.
I Dunno how you'd do it,
but just clogged that fucker up.
Okay.
And then just say I had to take a shit.
It was nowhere else to go.
I had to do it right.
And then you just say you went upstairs,
saw what the fuck it was,
and then you went back downstairs.
All right?
So that's what you do.
Clog up the toilet and just blame it on the fact that you had to take your shit.
Why am I helping you with this lie?
And it was funny to me.
Who gives a fuck?
There you go.
And that's what you do and then address it.
All right boy,
you just man up and just say listen.
All right,
the curiosity.
This is probably,
this is,
this is the man's way of doing it.
That's,
that's the bitch way of doing it.
So of course I know how to do that way.
The man just sits down and says,
listen,
all right,
who's fucking weirded me out that I can never go upstairs?
I just wanted to top of stairs and I looked to see what the fucking big deal
was,
you know,
like was it made out of gold?
You've got a sex slave up there,
you know,
there's some dead body.
What the fuck's going on up there?
And uh,
yeah,
that type of shit.
You know,
that's your world.
That's your life.
But uh,
that's not going to happen if we ever move in together.
All right?
And then she's going to give it,
I can't believe that you went upstairs when I told you not to.
You just broken the trust and they be like,
all right,
and let it just do it.
Let it get all of that out.
And then you go,
oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
What about you?
Okay,
so I just broke the trust.
But you know,
you're the one,
you Kinda,
you had this giant secret,
you got secret.
So you kind of fuck with the trust first.
You know,
you know there's a dead cat up there.
Do you understand that visit?
Fucking dead cat up there.
So I dunno.
Do,
do one thing or another.
You can do the pussy thing and do the toilet clogged up thing.
I gave you two options there,
sir.
The pussy bitch way or just be a fucking man.
Just take her out,
set it down and just say,
listen,
I gotta I got to tell you something.
All right.
Uh,
I feel ashamed that I did this,
but my curiosity got the best of me and I went to the top of stairs and I just
peeked to see what the big deal was with the upstairs.
Uh,
and you know,
then she'll probably start running away.
But you know,
women,
they don't know how to run.
Most of them.
Women can either run like a fucking track star or they just ran,
they run like it's you.
They run like toddlers.
Yeah.
You know,
so many of them,
I swear to God,
I'm not saying you don't see the and uncoordinated guy jogging every once in a
while,
but we,
you know,
we play sports.
We know how to run you guys.
I don't know what you do.
You sit around plotting,
making fucking rumors about each other.
Jesus bill.
Well,
you know what,
it took a while this week,
didn't it?
43 minutes in before I said some ignorant shit about women.
I'm getting better.
I had to get a nice clean half hour there.
Um,
so when she runs away from you like a,
you know,
somebody blew out her knee getting,
I'll just sort of jog behind her until she gets tired.
Um,
or just wait til she's wearing high heels until you tell her though,
that gives you an even better chance,
you know?
And as she's screaming,
screaming and boohooing and crying and all that,
you know,
he just walked behind it with the hands out.
You know,
looking at other people like,
you know,
you,
you do that classic,
you know,
this isn't my fault shit that that body language to other people,
which is basically you put your hands,
you know,
basically parallel to your shoulders straight out like that.
You know,
like you're going to shrug like a,
you know,
I dunno,
you haven't liked that.
And then after you do that,
then you bring them together in front of you,
motioning at her,
you know,
like,
Eh,
you bring them back out again.
High Minute.
Let me just,
she's,
she's just,
I don't know,
Eh,
right.
Just back and forth
and then you just say,
well we know something.
And as much as she gives a shit,
just be like,
you know what?
I'm glad I looked.
I'm glad I looked,
cause I didn't look,
I wouldn't,
I,
you know,
we got to talk about this.
I'm willing to help you through this and everything,
but I can tell you right now,
if you think you're going to move in with me and start doing that stuff,
there's going to be a mountain of shit getting thrown out every fucking week.
All right?
So there you go,
sir.
That is my advice.
That is my advice to your fucking ass.
Good luck to Ya.
All right,
Joe never slowed down.
God is screwing up going down.
Chad,
my sales guy,
this town.
Oh Man.
Oh hell yes.
Honey.
Butoh net body dress
drag.
Same is out.
Take my ass.
Cop caught the case.
[inaudible]
the fuck was I going to talk about the sea?
Oh,
guess what I did this week.
freckle face bill.
Guess what I did,
you know,
a year ago I wrote a fucking motorcycle or whatever.
I went dirt bike riding.
I actually took a motorcycle safety course.
It was a,
it was a day and a half,
and I got to tell you,
man,
it was fucking,
uh,
exhilarating and terrifying.
So I actually,
I passed the class somehow.
I don't think I should have.
I was doing my little ute turns.
I had to put my little foot down there.
Uh,
um,
no,
it was a great fucking time.
So basically how it worked was you wrote for like four hours and then you had a
class.
Um,
and I realized how spoiled I am as a fucking human being,
you know,
just having this,
the life that I have where I don't have a boss and I basically do whatever the
fuck I want.
I have not been in a classroom.
Um,
and I just immediately,
I just takes me back to why I chose the route I chose.
I just never liked the classroom situation,
but this,
this was a,
was actually a great time,
but I just immediately had anxiety and I'm like half paying attention and then,
and then in the end they're like,
okay,
now we're going to do the test.
And I went right back to when I was like in eighth grade and I got,
I've got,
I'm going to fail this.
The guy's like,
no one has ever failed this.
And he like,
Oh,
good pressure pressure.
I'm a moron.
We're sitting there at the table and everybody's fucking finishing.
Before I was like,
there was like,
I don't know,
40 people in the class.
I think I finished 37th as far as completing the test.
Um,
I don't know.
This is 50 questions.
I got four wrong,
something like that.
I'll fucking though.
But somehow I passed and um,
that was funny.
I've never flipped flops so much in my life on a decision.
I was thinking,
am I going to get a bike?
Should I just get a dirt bike?
Should I just know how to do this.
And then,
you know,
I just want to learn how to ride a motorcycle.
You know,
I grew up in the 80s all right.
I watched a lot of action movies and one of the things that I always was envious
of the Action Heroes Aside from their oiled up fucking eighties lifting weights,
no squats ever bodies was uh,
the fact that no matter what vehicle they approached,
not only with the keys always in it,
they knew how to drive it.
They knew how to drive everything from a dump truck to a fucking helicopter
airplane.
They could sail,
they could fucking do anything.
So,
you know,
it's coming up where,
we got to raise the debt ceiling again.
Eventually the wave's going to hit the beach and there's going to be a period
where you could quite possibly be getting chased down the street by an angry
fucking mob.
Is,
is just everything goes to shit,
you know?
So at that point it would be nice if you had the ability to,
whatever escape vehicle you meet you ran into,
you could actually just jump in and just be all right with it.
Right.
Sylvester Stallone,
Fucken uh,
Arnold Schwartzenegger,
Steven Seagal,
Chuck Norris,
they never,
and I challenge you to find anything that they fucking ran up to in any of those
movies that they did not jet ski,
fucking motorboat,
sailboat,
submarine,
combine helicopter,
fucking plane with,
with,
I only can land on water.
Those skis or the tires doesn't make a difference.
They could instrument rated the everything,
everything.
They could be on a fucking plane,
a commercial airline,
and somehow kill the person next to him,
put a hat over their face without anybody noticing,
crawl down into where the luggages and then jump off the landing gear and do a
fucking mash at the end of the,
the,
the runway.
They were unstoppable.
So I've added motorcycle.
All right.
I could drive a car stick or regular and now I can drive a motorcycle.
I'm just checking off the list.
I have a day and a half of experience now.
It was actually really fascinating and it made me a better driver.
And I actually have a much more appreciation of,
uh,
of this skill it takes to ride a motorcycle.
It's not like a car.
Yeah,
no shit bill now,
but just shit that you wouldn't think like I didn't,
I didn't understand all that went into just going around a turn on a motorcycle.
And now not only do you hit the,
do you not hit the break,
but if you hit the brake,
you're actually gonna you know you're going to crash.
You got to judge,
look through the whole turn,
judge you speed and then fucking power your way through it.
I'm pretty intense.
I got not going to lie to you.
I'm not gonna act like I was,
eh,
got this,
this is easy.
Then we would go into the class and like,
has anybody seen it?
And I'm getting excited like,
wow,
that I just rode a bike for four hours.
I've got it up to third gear,
down shift and this is fucking great.
And then I went into the class and one of the things,
you know,
the group discussion,
they was like,
anybody ever see a motorcycle accident are better than motorcycle accidents?
It's like fucking almost everybody,
or at least half the class puts their hands up and they start telling stories.
And this one guys was like a paramedic and he's going like,
yeah,
you know,
I saw this guy guy was going like 90 hit a car head on and his heart came out of
his chest.
He had like stories and I was sitting there,
I'm like,
like laughing to myself,
go,
what the fuck am I signing up for here?
This is insane.
Um,
yeah.
And then like the guy who was teaching the class who looked like he was born on
a motorcycle and was fucking,
you know,
rote the same way was,
obviously he's the instructor's fucking Great Ryan Bikes.
He even had a story of a couple months ago.
Yeah.
You know,
I hit some sand and I was like saying,
you know,
I'm going over the fucking handlebars and I'm like,
keep my body relaxed and all I'm thinking in my head is,
is like,
dude,
you went down,
you went down.
Yeah,
right.
This guy,
I'm telling you,
I'll just look like he was just made the right a fuck them.
You just had that.
I ride a motorcycle look,
as opposed to me who looks like some do.
She goes to take a safety course and I'm just thinking this guy went down,
this guy's an EMT talking about people's hearts coming out of their chest.
I'm just like,
what?
This is fucking stupid,
you know?
So,
uh,
yeah,
ion.
I don't know where I'm at.
I think I'm just gonna maybe just
right on dirt is what I'll do.
He can't,
you can't fucking ride a bike out here in la.
It's,
I,
you know what it is.
I'm old enough to know it's fucking stupid.
So a,
I think I'm going to,
if I'm going to do it,
I just get like a dirt bike and I'd put it in the back of my truck,
drive out of the city and all the people texting,
get to where the trailer is and then just ride around on dirt.
Now I know all you consume to be like actually mage and feet,
GLD jumping off road people,
no pa you can judge.
You need to,
I know I just stand this risk with everything,
but uh,
yeah.
You know,
I dunno.
I think it's a good thing that I waited till I was 45 to learn how to ride a
motorcycle because if I was thinking if I was 21 and I would just,
I wouldn't give a shit ass not going to happen to me.
That's not going to happen to me.
Like you get older and by the time you're,
my age,
shit has happened to you or some close friends.
So you kind of like,
yeah.
You know,
that could happen to me.
Kind of like my heart in my chest on this side of my rib cage.
Uh,
but I gotta tell you though,
I definitely got the bug and it's the most fucking fun.
I even by the second day,
I was actually getting frustrated
because I was thinking like,
I just want to take this out on the street.
I'm sick of speeding up and slowing down.
I just want to drive this fucking thing.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno.
Okay.
Don't worry,
I'm not going to go out and do that.
I'm not gonna do that dumb shit.
This is exactly what a lot of people do when they,
when they finally get to where they want to be in life,
which is where I feel I am.
You know,
selling tickets is a comic.
Get some acting gigs every once in awhile.
You know,
you got a little free time.
What do you do?
You pull a John Denver,
you go out and get a pilot's license,
you know,
you fly some experimental aircraft and next thing you know the,
the news today,
singer songwriter.
All right.
So that's definitely the back of my head.
But,
um,
I don't know.
I don't think knee is going to let me get one anyways.
To be honest with you,
that's probably a good thing.
But you know what she did when she was saying no,
she did the classic thing like why do you want to fuck like you know,
have all these toys but is it with guys and have you know,
you,
you have your,
and like what do I have?
I go,
I get my truck.
She goes,
you get your guitars.
And it's like,
you're upset with me cause I'm enjoying life.
And she's like,
no,
you know,
I think she just doesn't want me to get,
I'm so she tried to do that stupid argument that the motorcycle was this
extension.
Like it's like your Dick,
like you,
you guys like kids between their legs and they have ride this thing down the
street.
It's just like,
I dunno what the fuck that is about.
When I was riding for the last two days,
at no point was I thinking about my deck other than thinking like I hope I don't
fall off and uh,
when I'm going fast enough that I get road rash on my deck.
Okay.
That would be the only thing.
Other than that,
you know what,
I wish,
I wish she took the class with me.
You know,
that's what I was actually thinking.
It'd be great if she took the fucking class with me and she would just see how
much fun it is.
It's fun.
Okay.
You know,
I don't know.
Fucking know.
So,
uh,
I got the bug now.
I got the bug and I was looking at motorcycles all last night.
So I was telling her,
I said,
look,
all I want to do,
I'm just going to get like the Honda rebel.
It's a fucking two 50.
It's exactly what I should get when I start out.
If I get something else,
I'll kill myself.
And she starts,
you know,
looking up those stupid Ducati's,
which were cool about up until six months ago and now every douchebag out there
has them.
Like,
everybody seems to have one of those fucking things.
So,
you know,
I don't know.
I looked at the new Harley's and I don't like them.
I think they're ugly.
They kind of lost their way.
They lose.
They used to look meaner.
So I'm just going to get,
if I'm going to get one,
I'm either going to get a dirt bike or I'm going to get this little fucking two
50.
I think this speedometer only goes up to like 70 or 80.
Um,
I dunno.
Tell me,
what do you,
what do you guys think?
And this is,
and this is going to be one of those extreme,
uh,
conversations.
And believe me,
I've heard all the things get a motorcycle.
You might as well buy the coffin to go with it.
It's not a helmet,
it's a brain bucket.
I've heard all of that shit.
Um,
I dunno,
just a,
it does seem like a lot of fun,
right?
You know,
if I,
if I get one,
I'm going to be one of those douchebags who gets like a little two 50 and I'll
have like all the gear on and be dressed like all Samuelson.
If he ever rode a motorcycle flight completely over protected fucking robocop
suit on and I just ride around my neighborhood.
Never,
never get out of second gear.
Um,
anyway,
so that's what the fuck I did with my week.
But you know,
it's good to know though,
if I ever get chased by a bunch of people with hatchets down the street and I
happen upon a fucking motorcycle and there's a little key there provided it's
not an old one with the throttles,
the other side
or the shifter or whatever the fuck it is.
A I'll be able to,
I'll be able to escape,
you know.
All right,
fuck.
I'm talking about
[inaudible] this bitch on market square,
she's standing in her underwear looking down from a hotel room and that ball
will be coming soon.
Hell yes.
You got to pull it on app part injury as he was to go cry with a welcome alone
and him the last number.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It is the Monday morning podcast for a Monday,
October 5th,
2009.
How the hell are you?
Well that's good.
I'm actually fighting off disease this week.
I'm back here on the east coast and everybody is getting sick and uh,
I did a smart thing.
I actually fucking came home and I felt myself getting sick.
I took some vitamins and I just slept for like fucking 10 hours.
Um,
hence the podcast is a little bit late.
I apologize as always,
but um,
yeah man,
I had a great weekend.
I was out at this [inaudible] stress factory in New Jersey and I'm starting to
feel it,
man.
I'm starting to get on top of my game.
Um,
regular listeners,
you know,
I'm getting ready to do another special and um,
I've really put my time and with this one,
I did Sweden than I did Boston than I did Philly than I did Dallas.
And now I just did New Brunswick,
New Jersey five weeks in a row.
Now I had one week off between Sweden and uh,
and Boston.
And,
uh,
I gotta tell you,
man,
there's no substitute for that.
There really isn't.
I don't give a fuck.
You have to go out on the road.
You got to do this shows you gotta do six shows a weekend and you really have to
be like,
I'm really working on this one,
making sure the set order is right.
And uh,
you know,
cause that's,
that's how you gotta do it.
You want to have a memorable,
you don't just want to,
you know,
that's the worst fucking thing you can do,
I think in any,
any part of your life.
Work your ass off on something and then just get your reaction of like,
hey,
it was good.
I mean,
he went up there,
there was a microphone,
he was talking into it.
You could understand what he was saying.
Um,
he seemed to be having a good time.
What was he talking about?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I can't,
that's the thing I can't really remember,
but it was definitely English.
I know that because at no point I wasn't not comprehending what he was saying.
So I'm whatever,
I'm putting a little bit of pressure on myself.
I just,
you know,
the fuck you've got to keep trying to top yourself and a,
when you have a limited amount of skills that eventually,
you know,
I don't know,
it's a weird thing to try and turn to beat yourself.
How do you fake out yourself?
You know,
am I making any goddamn sense right now or is this fucking theraflu still,
uh,
kicking in here?
I'm actually fighting this shit off duty.
You want to talk?
I do this overrated underrated thing here on the podcast.
You know,
you want to talk a underrated,
underrated taking vitamins every goddamn day,
which is what I've been doing lately.
You know,
I take a,
I take a men's multivitamin.
I don't even know what it is.
I just know it's a brown with little black freckles of shit on it.
I have no idea what it is.
I've been taking that his vitamin B supplement so I don't get Alzheimer's cause
evidently,
uh,
I took a physical and they were telling me,
you know,
I'm not even gonna say that cause I'm trying to get health insurance right now.
That's the preexisting condition.
Now we brought that up.
Well maybe it's the all timers.
Maybe that's why you don't remember it.
MMM.
[inaudible]
yeah,
that's the how kind of health insurance I have right now.
And I want to get some other health insurance.
The health insurance I have right now basically covers everything except what I
go,
you know,
to the dentist for,
I want to get a fucking cleaning and they didn't cover it.
A cleaning.
I mean that's ground zero.
And they're saying because the lady used that,
that electronic pick,
which a lot of them use just because they are lazy,
not that Lazy.
They,
they,
you know,
back in the old days where they used to just use the scraper,
then the,
the,
the manual scraper for your teeth.
Now they just use the,
uh,
the other one.
I mean I hadn't gone in in a little bit.
So the first time I went in I understood that she used it,
but now I've been going in there like every fucking four months,
you know,
four months.
You don't need to use that electronic one.
You fucking lazy.
But for some reason my health insurance,
oh we only,
we only just cover if they just use with use it with their hands.
Yeah.
By the way,
you owe us another 350 bucks for this quarter.
I'll go fuck yourselves.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I am on tour like a maniac right now.
Um,
now I've got maniac,
like somebody is getting ready to do a special.
So I am actually in New York City right now sitting in my old apartment and uh,
it's bringing back memories of when I used to fucking live here and I would get
sheared faced and bang a Ho whore.
Um,
[inaudible]
I like this place.
I'm going to try and keep it,
you know,
this is my just in case I get divorced place someday,
cause I'll go out and I'll buy a house and God knows my girl will get that,
you know,
and then fill our kids up with her version of who I am,
you know?
Then I come by on Saturdays to pick them up and then they got that look on their
face.
You know,
like they just had some horrific story told.
Wow Man,
I'm really in a bad mood right now.
Just not even a bad mood.
I'm just fucking negative.
You know what?
Why don't we try and turn this around by me giving you guys,
I'll,
I'll do a little ass build hill build here
or you know what?
Fuck that.
Why don't I hype what I have coming up this weekend?
I have,
I'm going to be at the Improv in a,
I think it's homestead,
Pennsylvania,
right outside of Pittsburgh.
It's called the,
the,
the stacks,
I believe it's that mall right at right up,
you know,
right over the bridge that goes over the river.
Get Out.
It's basically one of those things.
It's classic America right now.
It's basically,
it's a place where Americans used to have union jobs and they made steel for
fucking American cars in American buildings and now it's a mall and you go in
there and you buy shit that was made from people in other countries probably by
their children for one 90th of what they were paying in American.
But as a tribute to those Americans,
they used to have jobs.
They kept it,
they kept the smokestacks from the old steel factory,
steel mill factory.
Actually the last time I was fucking there,
I actually kind of researched that area cause I was kind of fascinated by it.
And I found out that there was some big,
big battle between the workers and they called in police and the,
and some militia to beat down these Americans who wanted to get a fair wage and
people got their head split open.
They fucking died right there on those riverbanks,
you know,
so people could make money and I don't know what happened.
My generation,
we just sat around eating double cheeseburgers and an all fucking left.
But anyways,
I'll be down there telling my jokes.
Hey and look who's back.
Look who's back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Joe to Rosa,
young Joe to Rosa and Joe,
you know I'm gonna love about Joe.
Is Joe's actually going to come in,
he's going to join the podcast and at no point is he ever going to address that.
Actually,
I already did this podcast for 45 minutes before I realized that I didn't have
any batteries in my recorder and he's gonna sit down like a goddamn pro.
Listen,
this is the deal.
People always ask me,
you know when the hell you ever gonna have a guest.
Every once in a while you should switch it up.
You should get a guest like out a guest,
a disgruntled,
I already did this for free for 45 minutes.
Joe,
let me tell you something,
man,
you was so funny this past hour on this podcast that didn't get recorded.
Thank you.
And I have belief in you that there's a lot more funny in that.
Well,
Joe was actually a,
if you're new to the podcast,
I'm,
Joe is a,
this is the worst joke because I've already done this and it's fucking Monday.
I'm sorry.
It's all right.
All right Joe.
Ah,
still worse.
We gave that guy great advice.
And now,
right now we're going to have to read it again and pretend like we already
didn't do it or we'll,
it'll be fine.
We'll get through it.
I do it.
I'll tell you an inspirational story,
Joe,
so we can get through this the second time.
Brian Johnson of ACDC fame.
All right.
One time told his story about Phil Rudd,
that drummer,
they have band.
And he said basically they had some unbelievable take of some song and for some
reason they ran out of tape right in the mid,
right in the middle of the greatest part of the song ever.
And it had been built to like this emotional apex,
you know,
so the guy goes in the guide,
the fucking guy behind the,
uh,
the mixing board is all devastated.
He's apologetic and he's like,
I can't believe in somehow,
whatever.
They have to somehow get,
they lost Phil Rudd Shit.
Right?
All right.
And the guy's like,
oh my God,
we're never gonna get it today.
I fucked up.
I'm so sorry.
And then Phil Rev was just like,
just play the tape again,
mate.
I'm going to jump right in.
And he goes,
there's no way you can do it.
He goes,
just roll the fucking tape.
And they roll it to it and he jumps in seamlessly.
Like he went back in time and he fucking totally nails the take.
He plays it even fucking better than they did the first time they hit.
They stop the thing and the fucking guy behind the board,
he's just completely flabbergasted because,
cause that was unblind never seen anybody do anything like that.
You're,
you're fucking unbelievable.
And fell was sitting there with that cigarette dangling,
dangling from his lips and he just goes,
I know
Brian Johnson tells it better,
but that's your inspirational story there,
Joe.
So anyways,
Joe de Rosa,
me and Joe do this.
There's wonderful radio show that used to be on XM.
Used to be on XM Sirius.
Yeah,
sometimes it is,
but you know what?
I don't know.
There was a merger and just like you guys out there going through this tough
economy,
I guess we were the odd man out there was a merger.
They took our money away.
They left us with nothing.
You know what they really did?
And we just decided we would tired of waiting nine months for a fucking $35
check.
Isn't that what basically I'll be honest here.
Oddly enough we,
we,
we see more disappointed than XM does.
Yeah.
About the show head.
We keep reading the trade magazines waiting for that XMC or Sirius XM exome is
really called the say what happened where,
whatever.
Do your show saying that their stock plummeted another two fucking is it points
a dollars.
We don't know what the points,
let's go with points.
Anyways,
the name of the show we did was called uninformed.
Uh,
no reading,
no research,
just strong opinions.
And if you haven't picked it up yet,
a,
me and Joe were a couple of fucking morons and uh,
no point should you ever really listen to anything that we say.
You know what you want,
why do we do,
you know,
we really do our show for other than the Hora sells out so we can make more
money and not have to go on the road shaking hands of people who have fevers
that are then going to pass it on to you as you get to wash your hands and eat a
fucking order of Mozzarella sticks between the first and second show like I did.
Um,
who do,
who else do we do it for?
You should,
you know who is what?
We do it for the fuck.
Sorry,
I'm,
I have no train of thought.
We fucking,
we do it for you,
for you.
If my 15 fucking listeners so you guys can feel better about your lives to be
like price.
Yeah.
No,
not even advice.
Just when you hear a fucking stupid we are,
you can actually in the like,
well these guys actually have some sort of fast radio show.
You know?
I can make it too.
Yeah,
I agree.
It's good.
It makes people feel like they can achieve out there.
Yeah,
they may.
It makes people feel like they can get to our level because you certainly can.
This is an attainable level in life.
Absolutely.
We are not,
well,
I mean I'm speaking for myself,
you know,
but you too can be on the internet making no money whatsoever and not have a
boss.
There's something freeing about it.
Joe.
Joe,
I'm telling you all we need is a windmill and our own garden in the back and
what?
We'll be fucking good.
We'll just go veggie.
What would you plant in the garden bill?
A couple cherry tomatoes.
Tomatoes.
Let me tell you something.
[inaudible] button.
Do you know how bad I want to buy a fucking house so I can have a garden?
I love having gardens.
I want to,
I want to have a garden and be,
that guy was slowly loses his mind out there.
Talking to the plants because he's breathing into pesticides.
You know?
That's why I want to be just,
Oh look at that.
Zucchini
shaped like a girl I used to know,
but
my uh,
my dad had,
uh,
had an astounding garden when I was growing up.
I think that that's one of the coolest things ever to be able to walk into your
backyard.
Okay.
Like,
and have your own food supply.
I think there's something really like,
I think that we've kind of got everybody living in a culdesac.
I really think that,
you know what I would love to do,
you know,
you would get whacked by the fucking powers that be,
but if you could just somehow teach people how to build windmills and if they
somehow just couldn't stop it,
you know,
the same way like fucking that,
that auto auto tron,
what the fuck?
What kind of music is that took over?
You know,
that music Jay-Z's ran auto tune auto tune the same way that that just took over
and the government couldn't do anything about it.
Like what if,
what if people just started windmills?
You can build a windmill.
That's not illegal.
Now you can't,
sure you can and you can't.
Why?
Because,
um,
general electric is worried that you're not going to make one that's safe.
So they still need to go out there and inspect it to make sure.
No,
they did a whole fucking thing out in California where they,
once again,
they squeezed out the little guy and this is what they're doing,
Joe,
as we move into a greener ways,
as we're moving into group,
the reason why it's taking so fucking long for us to move into greener things is
because first of all,
there's still a lot more money to be made with the old things.
And then also the guy,
the the fucking,
there will be blood guys gotta make sure that they're still in control of it,
you know,
that's my fucking solution to the Middle East.
You want to beat those cock suckers over there.
Just fucking make cars run on fruit loops or water or whatever the fuck we can
over here and people can do stand mayor came up with something on a long island.
How to make you make it run on water.
Okay.
How do these fucking terrorists get their money?
As far as I know,
Joe and I don't know a lot.
I believe that the money that we spend on all their fucking oil goes to the,
the they,
they had a rab over there.
They had the,
the,
the fucking Shah or whatever the fuck is called and then he sits there and acts
like he's down with America while he subtly is sending money off to the Hamas
and the al Qaeda and all that.
So we stopped fucking using that.
That God damn energy,
they'd go bankrupt over there.
You ain't got no money.
Joe Yank got no boosts.
You ain't got no Bougie.
Ain't got no guns.
What does that for a,
we ain't got no booze,
but we had kind of ones that from Kelly's heroes or circular telly Savalas or is
it from dirty dozen?
That was telly Savalas yelling at fucking Don Rickles.
You never saw Kelly's heroes.
Oh,
Kelly's heroes is a fucking great movie and it's hilarious because it doesn't
make sense because it's about world war two,
but it has the hippy Vietnam vibe.
It's right during that time with the directors took over in Hollywood like,
fucker,
we're going to do it our way yet.
Did you know up until like that,
like for the longest time that the director's job was basically only to make
sure that the actors were on their mark and that everything was in frame?
I don't even think they were responsible to make sure about the lines.
No,
there was the studios operated like factories dude.
Yeah.
And the second you said,
and that's a wrap.
You left and the studio took the picture and they cut it up.
It's amazing.
Right?
That's why guys like Billy Wilder,
we're so renowned in the,
uh,
cause he did that in the 50s right?
Yeah.
He was being a real director in the 50s you know what I mean?
W it so basic.
What happens.
So with the Kelly's heroes thing,
by then what you had was you had that young generation that was taking over and
they will making a World War II movie and they had Kiefer Sutherland played this
southern,
sorry,
Donald Sutherland was playing this hippie a this sorta,
you know,
I don't know.
They had like their own like uh,
they had their own way of doing things,
man.
But it was funny.
It was before hippies became like played out and annoying.
You know who's like head guy?
Gavin Macleod,
isn't it?
Who's the head guy that Clint Eastwood,
Clint Eastwood Dude,
they got all the guys,
guys,
Clint Eastwood,
Telly Savalas,
Don Rickles,
Donald Sutherland.
Uh,
I think that guy who played angel on the Rockford files is in it.
I can't remember.
Gavin Macleod who used to be on May.
Hey,
they may,
he used to play Mary Tyler Moore from the love boat right here.
He's from Mary Tyler Moore,
the love boat.
That was that I'm saying.
He's the captain of the love boat and that was his cash grab.
He's like,
I'm old.
I can't believe I keep getting work.
But that little fucking mustaches,
little parents shorts being all tanned up,
little white shorts to the greatest exit and non flame out from drugs ever was
the guy who played Gofer on the love boat.
Dude,
you're on a show.
It's called the love boat.
Your character's name is gopher and you're wearing shorts like you're on a
cruise ship with those white socks yanked up to your fucking knees like you're
the ABA.
Right.
Okay.
Your career is over.
You're going to take all anybody else,
any less of a fucking man would have taken all that money.
Okay?
You would have found Donny most and you would've sent it up.
You fucking knows.
I shouldn't have set him.
He didn't do that.
Drugs,
whatever you find out Lawrence McCutchen or whatever name is.
What's that NZ fill with Kenzie fit?
Yeah.
Lawrence McCutchin is the old running back from fucking the Baltimore Colts.
But anyways,
that's what you would do.
He had the fucking wherewithal to be like,
I'm go for,
I'm on the love boat.
This is it.
What else do I want to do?
I'm into politics.
He went on.
He became a fucking state senator.
Which one was go for the black guy.
No,
that was Isaac Hayes.
I know it wasn't.
It was Isaac Curtis.
That's another fight.
Isaac Curtis was a fucking wide receiver for the boy.
No,
no,
no.
You know who the fuck that was?
Oh,
you man.
You know what's funny about which were when the were,
I got a great,
which one was go for the hold on,
go for was the guy with the glasses.
Now the doctor who got all the pussy for no fucking reason.
That made no sense.
He had him.
Then you had Gavin Macleod.
Then you had,
you had the bartender who did the double point.
That was the black,
you know,
like a half the def jam had shots of the late eighties I'm getting confused.
I'm getting there.
I mean he was,
he kept McCloud was the ball guy.
I was saying mustache.
I was getting Barney Miller confused with Gavin Macleod.
Oh yeah,
dude.
Here to play.
[inaudible] he was probably on that fucking show.
The point is,
there was a guy on that show.
He was a series regular.
His name was gopher to dark hair.
Yes.
Okay,
I remember.
Now let's,
let's go through.
Let's go through some sitcoms.
Joe,
let's name awful character names.
Well,
you know,
you're not Urkel Dun,
Dun Schneider.
Schneider done like [inaudible].
When you don't skippy Outta here.
Skippy family ties.
He's not doing Carmody now.
Yeah,
Joe.
Yeah.
Yes he is.
Squealer was that kid on fucking saved by the bell screech.
Screech squealing.
I'm still dumbfounded that I,
when you said Lawrence,
what did you call as McCutchen cause it's so good.
I knew it was Rickettsii.
That's so close.
Know it was like some sort of pig Latin.
No,
wait a minute.
They're all done.
Potsy Potts and done Ralph mouth done.
Every actor in Hollywood,
Fonzie even Fonzie's done.
This is the thing squigy squigy Outta here.
Out of there.
This is a thing as as a fucking,
as an actor,
you have to instinctively know that if your character does not have a first and
a fucking last name,
it's already been doing this.
Please.
It's already going to be,
yeah,
absolutely.
Joe Will Mount this as much as we can and it's still actually recording.
Dude,
if you don't have like a real fuck and a name that you could walk out in public
with Alex p Keaton.
Okay.
He kept going.
He just had the unfortunate of getting sick and he was even sick and he was able
to do a western way.
Spin City.
They're both about the same shit,
dude.
I watch sports.
I don't watch that.
The West Wing is about the White House.
Spin City was about him worker for a governor.
It's politics.
You just be happy.
I didn't say Benson again,
like no,
there you go.
Benton.
There's one God.
Who Benson the fuck is that guy done?
What does Robert Yom done since Benson.
Yeah,
but he was,
he was like 70 when he finally got that and I'll do it.
I'm talking about to get out of here.
Bence is not a bad name.
I,
somebody came in.
If a guy said,
my name is Benson,
but you're saying a one name character gone.
Dude.
I'm more talking about like you.
Your name is fucking zippy.
Big Ragu gone.
See you later.
The Big Red Goop gone.
Uh,
uh,
who was the guy,
that ae on family ties?
Nick.
His name wasn't Moose.
No,
it was nick.
His name was nick on the show.
His Moose Moose from that fucking show where those dick kids show,
they would step out of the locker television.
Yeah.
That was moose.
But hey to her.
Hey Jerry.
Yeah.
Moose.
She didn't even look like a moose.
Yeah,
it was just such a mean nickname.
It really wasn't [inaudible].
Yeah,
I love that show.
That that was a great shoe.
They used to torture kids.
Remember they did the firing squad.
They'd shoot the kids and shit.
That was a great show.
Red Now.
Yeah.
They did these to do a sketch.
It was on Nickelodeon and they used to do a sketch where they had that one guy
that played all the grownups on the show.
He was the one actor,
and he would fish.
He did like,
he would do like a Nazi character.
He was like any last words.
And the kid would say something and he'd make a one-liner and they'd shoot the
kid.
And then they,
he did another character called barf where he ran a restaurant and he was
disgusting.
He would always pick his nose and the kids eat and there would be like,
you know,
they would go,
uh,
they'd say something like,
you know,
I saw a dead squirrel in the street when I was on my way in here.
And then barf would pop up and you go,
uh,
what do you think should in the Burger?
That was his catchphrase and he was putting nasty shit.
So needless to say,
he never worked again.
What was his character's name?
He,
he was the guy that played all the male grown up care.
He played everybody.
I was in the,
when I was working in Denver,
um,
I'm doing,
I,
I made a reference to family ties and at the end of the show,
this guy comes up to me,
tad it out,
tattoos all over him and he's fucking twitching a little bit.
And he goes,
Hey,
uh,
and his buddy comes up going,
hey,
you like family ties,
right?
He's like,
yeah,
this kid was one of the guys on it.
And I'm looking at him,
he's in like in his twenties.
And I'm like,
who the fuck was he?
He played the little kid.
Why was he twitching?
Ah,
he said you
probably saw me on TV getting arrested for drugs and drinking and driving.
I've been sober for six months and and so his buddy who's hanging out with them
went to take,
you know,
wanted a picture with,
so we go to take a picture and that the former child star there is holding the
camera's hands are shaking and the kid with me goes,
uh,
look,
look at his handshake and look at his hand shaking and it really fucking pissed
me off and I want to be like,
you know what to do.
This kid's just hanging out with you because your fucking you right now.
Like he shouldn't be saying that.
If that's a true friend,
who the fuck would be saying that this kid is trying to be sober and he's making
fun of your fucking hands twitching and he's just a total cunt and he's just
trying to get a picture with me cause I've been on,
I love the eighties yeah,
he's just this fucking pathetic level star fucker.
He's like half a star fucker.
Yeah.
I just remember that stuck out.
It really annoyed me and I felt bad for that kid.
You could just,
you know,
if you know something,
do you know why I take some of those stuff?
Those the child star kids flameout is because what kind of a fucking kid wants
to have to memorize lines?
Like who tries to make it at five [inaudible] kid did it right man.
The youngest kid from,
from frogs,
taxi driver or us?
Cynthia Phillips.
Cindy Williams.
Now,
not her fucking uh,
uh,
B beaver.
Beaver clam.
What?
The 40 foster Jodie foster beaver.
Claire [inaudible].
How does that have to do that?
Those rooms?
She was gay.
I was like,
oh,
that's my like me brainstorm.
That's how I get,
I get diver.
I think,
you know,
I'm not trying to be like,
am I sound like I'm home a homophobic,
I was trying to give you clues like,
look what I do when I can't remember shit.
I just start acting like I'm on the $10,000 pyramid.
We have a clam.
Ah,
Johnny Foster.
I'm telling you what kid did it right.
Was the youngest kid from a home improvement.
I watched one of those Hollywood children or Hollywood specialist or whatever
and he uh,
he left the business.
He just walked away when the,
when it was done,
he didn't care anymore.
Yeah,
he went out.
He married some girl.
He followed some girl.
Who is this?
I wasn't even listening in the beginning.
The youngest kid from home improvement.
The one,
the youngest kid.
Like he's like earth.
Michael Taylor Thompson.
No,
no,
no.
He was the middle kid.
He he must see the body.
No,
no,
no.
The youngest kid.
I hated that show.
Dude.
I welcome that talk.
I forget that part of it.
I'm just saying he left show business as a child.
Sorry.
I was like fuck it.
I'm out of here.
He went out to the Midwest.
He started deejaying cause that's what he wanted to do.
He married some shit way,
way,
way.
What?
He started deejaying.
Hey started you.
He just like started DJ and for fun that would tell you of a promise white guy.
Shit DJ.
And they opened a Vegan restaurant and he was like,
this is what I do is my life.
I live a very pure,
healthy life.
Like he just had,
he was just so collected.
There was not an,
he's like,
yeah,
maybe one day I'll go back and ag.
I don't know,
whatever man.
Like he just didn't care.
He wasn't one of these fucking,
you know Dana platos which guy wasn't?
Cause I gotta tell you something.
Those kids,
I don't know if they would take an HGH,
but something happened to the skulls of the kids on that show,
which show that home improvement.
Well,
nothing happened to skull.
They look like they were in fun house mirrors by the end of it,
they were going through puberty and like did they have fucking foreheads with
jut now they've d they were adorable kids when they first got,
that's the thing about,
about like you get those kids is their puppies.
This,
you're very hard pressed to find a puppy that isn't cute,
but you know,
you can have an ugly dog.
And that's what I'm saying.
A lot of those kids were ugly dogs.
Yeah.
They kind of turned like,
yeah,
like I think at least two of the three kids on home improvement were on Roids
[inaudible] and Terry Thomas is still a pretty decent looking kid.
He was,
he had the pianist,
he looked like he had that composer hair.
He looked like he was in bugs bunny,
like he was gonna Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Like I can't get tails on go.
You should always be wearing tales,
you know?
You know what's actually tapping into right now?
Joe Is my fucking memory problem.
Like I,
I can't remember people's names and I can't remember the names of places.
Like there's a breakfast place.
Me and Neil love out now,
the west coast and they have like these big,
huge biggest pancakes you ever saw in your life.
Biggest French toast and always putting like whipped cream and all this shit and
it's fucking Riddick.
It's mayhap right,
but you eat it,
huh?
Here's your always against eating shit like that.
Yeah,
but there's their French toast dude is ridiculous.
I know.
I don't do like the whip bite.
I just see people going by and they got like a whole stick of butter on it and
we bend that 200 times.
I can't remember the fucking name of the place you remember right now?
No.
I finally remembered it's called the griddle,
but for the longest time I was calling,
I was calling it our pancake circus.
I liked the griddle.
I'd been there.
Oh,
I do this.
What?
I'm trying to explain you why I say the composer because what I can,
I remember certain details.
I remember he had that long fucking Beethoven haircut.
So then it becomes that.
That's really fun.
And then what it does is then I throw it out there and then you go,
no,
no.
And then you say the name and I kind of am able to joke my way through the fact
that I can't remember shit.
I'm with you.
I'm with you pal.
Yeah.
All right there buddy.
I want to help you get through this.
Okay.
We get through this bill.
I just realized I am fucking star Dude.
I know.
I feel like I'm going to pass out,
no offense,
but how much longer?
How much longer do I have to do free shit?
Well,
it's free,
so technically I can fucking cut it off whenever I can,
whenever I want to.
Why don't we want Joe when?
When are we actually going to be able to start?
Me and Joe de Rosa,
as you've noticed,
have just a tremendous chemistry when we get on the microphones and shit.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
On the one and two,
yeah.
That's where we do that podcast sign.
So listen,
so we're,
we're going to start doing these on a show.
Why can't we upload these fucking things onto the internet?
Look,
here's the deal.
We had this show called uninformed and then we started to do it as a podcast and
we're going to sell it for a buck.
An episode on the web.
I mean on the iTunes.
Yeah,
because we're actually can,
I can't get the guidance things to upload.
Let me,
let me,
let me jump in here.
And the reason why we're charging a dollar and episode people is because we're
actually going to have guests.
We're going to have interviews,
we're going to be doing things.
I mean,
it's a fucking radio show and I know you,
people on the Internet don't like to pay for Shit.
It's a dollar an episode for the love of God.
You know?
It was that,
was that the fucking worst way ever to try.
I love how just nowadays as an artist,
you have to justify that,
that you know that your time is valuable.
Even if we don't have guests,
which we will have episodes where we don't,
you know,
we used to get paid to do the show.
It's work to do the show.
We have to,
we have to book gigs on the road.
You want to go to that bar and I want to find that guy who came up with that
cheeseburger and talked to him and just talk to him up just about food in
general.
There's a government agent try to take that guy out right now.
He isn't.
Probably works for him.
Look Joe,
your weight,
we talked about that cheeseburger in the last one.
I don't think you got it on.
Did I not talk about it in this one?
I didn't.
No,
I can't remember.
All right,
this is,
this is a fucking,
okay.
Just to fucking go back.
I talked about that fried butter a week ago and how like there's just insane
levels of like why,
okay.
I was in,
I was watching the Patriots game yesterday.
Joe Shit,
I know you're a big sports fan.
You know that they one bill the other day,
one buddy that we got lucky against the ravens again,
the ravens have beaten us the last two times we played them and somehow,
I don't know what happens.
They fucking,
they make a bonehead play.
They played,
they pull it out of pocket.
I would say that someone,
yeah,
patriots,
they could,
they pull it out of the pocket.
I'll tell you.
No one can talk sports like Joe Joe.
Why did the Patriots beat the Ravens?
Cause Their GI bill.
Overall,
I just think they're a better team and when they're put under the gun they
deliver.
You could actually get away with that on a,
on a sports talk show.
It's another one.
You have to incorporate it.
This is another thing.
If somebody asks you what's wrong with the Patriots,
all you've got to start as this way.
I got to tell you,
if I'm the Patriots right now,
I gotta be thinking and then just,
you don't have that.
All you got to do is just throw anything in there and you'll be fine.
I'll tell you two things at two things.
I've been right about.
Two things that I called this season.
Joe was,
everyone was fucking jumping all over Sanchez,
the jets quarterback,
you know him?
Yeah.
Well Sanchez,
there's heat on that guy for no reason.
And uh,
you know,
I think he's a good player.
I mean,
he deserves a little leeway.
I like how you just said two things that,
no,
I said at the beginning of the season,
I mean the,
they called the guy a star after he beat the Texans.
I mean,
he's going to be a star.
It's not a star yet.
And I called it with my buddy.
I said,
dude,
he is gonna have that horrific pick six.
I'm a fucking rookie and he had it yesterday and I also called Matt Castle when
they send them over to Kansas City and everyone's like,
how the fuck are the Patriots?
Get rid of my,
said he was driving a Ferrari last season.
That's all he had to do was keep it on the fucking road and he went 11 and five
right now you're going to Kansas City.
All of a sudden you're not driving a Ferrari anymore.
No,
you don't even drive in a z 28 now you've got to Camaro rally sport.
That's what you got with the v six and you chicks driving it.
What I like about Matt Castles,
Matt is real players player and,
all right,
let's,
let's end it.
Let's do a new segment.
We're just sports [inaudible] talk with Chodo Rosa.
We'll just do fake sports talk for as long as I can.
I'll just,
okay,
but you,
you talk real sports and I'll,
I'll just fake through it.
I think we got it.
Joe.
I think me and the listeners understood the premise while you were doing it,
Joe,
what made Tony Doors set the running back that he was
Tony Door's set.
You know,
you know,
he had the legs of a champion.
He's just the guy who could run no matter what he could run.
And that's the most important thing when a running back is that they run.
These guys are out here talking about his style Gel.
Talk about his style isn't running back.
Like who would you compare him to his style.
Look,
you know,
when running backs,
I'm looking for a Mike Quick,
uh,
I'm looking for a guy that drills and runs that guy head down,
shoulders up.
He knew how to plow through it and that's what you need.
Delivery to the end zone.
Okay.
You know,
it's amazing is how you will almost fucking almost,
you're saying it's fucked up enough where people would still be looking at each
other like,
dude,
this guy doesn't watch sports.
But then you write as you think that,
then you're like,
oh,
maybe he does head down.
That makes sense.
Shoulders up.
How do you have [inaudible] head down in your,
how do you have your own shoulders up?
All right.
Yeah,
let's,
let's get back to the sandwich.
So before this whole thing goes off the rail.
So I'm sitting at this fucking Bar,
right?
Cause that's what I do.
Do I drink during the day?
Let's say Latino.
Yeah.
I don't have anything to live for.
It's all about killing the silence.
The road is,
I will say it's just waiting for the next meal.
Just waiting for the next meal.
For the next meal.
Please share the clank of the silverware.
That's all you want to do.
Joe Killed The loneliness.
All right,
so let's plow ahead here.
So I'm sitting at this bar,
right?
And I'm watching the game with this guy and this guy calls the bartender ordered
over to order some food and he goes,
yeah,
listen,
I want to order you.
Sure.
I didn't tell it on this one.
I'm not positive,
but I'm pretty sure tell it again.
Yeah.
Gives a shit.
That's a great,
yeah.
Cause we were talking about,
remember it led us on,
did a KFC shit and everything.
We didn't,
we didn't talk about that shit.
All right,
so anyways,
so the guy calls the bartender over and he goes,
yeah.
I goes,
yeah,
listen,
I want to order a custom burger.
And I'm like,
who the fuck does that?
Who Fuck or is a customer?
Well,
evidently this guy had this burger at this bar in New Jersey.
It's called a duck buster.
D U C K.
Buster.
I gotta give these guys credit because they really went above and beyond.
So evidently this dude ate it and he loved it so much.
He goes to this bar and he goes to order some listening to him order and the guy
goes,
all right,
what do you want?
He goes,
all right,
this is what I want you to do.
It's like that Jack Nicholson thing.
I want you to hold it between your knees.
It's like that fucking thing.
He basically goes,
I want you to make two grilled cheese sandwiches with tomato and bacon in them.
He goes to grow yet two grilled cheese sandwiches with tomato and Bacon.
And then I want you to you to use those two grilled cheese sandwiches as the
bread for the cheeseburger.
So the two sandwiches where the Bun?
Yeah.
And then he see you were totally blown away the first time,
but you already heard it so it's just gets through the no,
it was taken.
Then he had another fucking,
then he had like a half pound of beef in there with cheese on of that.
And I will say it again.
That sounds amazing.
And if I could get it right now,
I'd go get it.
The problem is we're getting at the problem is the product costs him $20 because
you know,
yeah,
that's like two,
two words of a grill.
This is what,
you know what Yo,
I would eat that.
I really gel.
Yeah.
Like I didn't fucking know that I would eat it.
You know what?
One time I was sitting here shooting the shit with Joe and I didn't realize
until he got to his second donut that he was actually just sitting across from
me eating a bag of donuts,
donuts.
It was like two in the afternoon.
Joe.
What I've seen you on many occasions eat pain cakes with chocolate chips and
shit and no,
you haven't banana bananas.
That's good for you,
but that's for do pancakes.
You know worse the God damn doughnut dude,
it's fresh.
Not at her Joe,
but I don't have the knowledge to fucking actually back up that.
I know I'm right.
Pancakes are not as bad as donuts.
Donuts.
You're trying to get fat.
You're trying to get,
you take a stack of pancakes.
You put butter and syrup on them.
You think that's that?
Any that a stack of [inaudible] though.
It's fucking pure sugar.
Having an orgy with butter.
What's it a pancake?
Pure.
It's not pure sugar.
Doughnuts are better there than nut Joe.
Let me tell you somebody not,
but don't you don't.
You don't.
Don't you?
Fuck you.
Don't know.
You don't how to make one.
Joe,
you've,
you've made a donut bill.
It's better that you DSI.
It's sugar coagulating with butter.
That's all it is.
Bill,
you're wrong.
I am not wrong.
You're making this up right John,
I'm gonna kick you off this fucking show.
I got wrong on my own podcast.
Rip and Tonitto but it's,
it's bread.
Dude.
I know.
What is your content?
It's not as bad as a pancake though.
[inaudible] not healthy,
but it's not as bad as case stacks.
Y'All.
First of all,
shout out one doughnut.
2:00 PM.
It's the same thing.
Fucking face.
You're wrong,
Joe.
First of all,
a fucking does nothing.
Don't you don't disrespect pancakes.
No,
I don't ever.
I'm going to tell you I have a fucking Pankey.
You know pancakes like pancakes.
I like that buddy of yours who you don't want anybody to talk shit about.
But you know this slightly retarded.
That's what pancakes are from me.
That's how I used to fucking,
no,
you don't understand the rules.
You have to go to your little fucking pitch.
No,
that's not it.
That's how they used to make money on the road when I was on the road and I
wasn't making shit and I'm out there by my fucking self not talking to anybody.
Back to fly.
Even at a fucking cell phone,
Joe,
a lot of people didn't have cell phones in the late nineties I was one of them.
Okay.
And I fucking why be out there in the middle of Goddamn nowhere?
No actually by then I got a cell phone but I'd been so in the middle of nowhere.
It was like on that roaming thing and this is how I would make money cause I
wasn't making any fucking money,
is what I would do is I would either go to Denny's or I would go to the IHUB and
I would get their large stack of five and dude it is not sugar.
It's like fucking cement.
And you would just pour that in and it would mold to the shape of your stomach
and it would sit there and dude,
you eat that at fucking eight,
nine in the morning and then go do a nooner and then drive to Colorado schools
or the mines or some fucking Rhinelander Wisconsin fucking Gig.
And you would not be hungry for 12 hours.
And that way I was able to skip meals and,
and I,
and I could cut down on my food costs.
Okay.
You tell me you eat a sack of fucking donuts in the morning and you can go 12
hours without eating.
You can't.
First of all,
you'd pass out behind the fucking wheel because of all that sugar.
And you know,
that's fucking true.
Joe,
I want you to retract your statements about pancakes.
I will not tell you.
We'll deal with the ramifications of this Joe,
because I have podcast listeners and they are very vocal and they email.
I,
uh,
it's not as bad as a fucking doughnut.
This is where you're,
you're not listening to what I'm saying.
I'm saying a statue of NOI makes is bad as one donut and let's say in a pile of
donuts is equal to a pile of pinkish.
Okay,
wait a minute.
We need a stack of pancakes.
No,
that's as bad as eating one doughnut.
I disagree.
Let's look it up on the Goddamn Internet round.
Look,
Joe,
cause kids,
what you're doing is you're equating quality,
uh,
calories to being equally bad.
Okay?
Look,
Joe,
I can eat fish shot you.
I did Joe.
I can eat.
I can eat fucking 400 calories of apples and you can eat 400 calories of donuts.
What the fuck is worse built?
Pancakes are not full stop.
You're going to shit yourself,
Joe.
There's nothing about pancakes that are good for you at all.
All right,
shit they got,
did they ever put fucking bananas or any sort of fruit on the side?
When you get a donut,
they don't.
You put fruit to pay fluid.
They fill out a delicious,
delicious fruit.
Do you know what that time to make the donuts guide Jesus into him.
That's what the fucking fill out is.
Whatever is every once in a while I'd like to be a first grader bill.
I like a little donut here and there.
You know there's nothing wrong with it.
I think a lot of hate saying it like you're like a finger in your ass.
I like that too.
All right,
let's move on here.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go to the advice thing.
We have to actually do some stuff.
We've got 40 minutes here,
Joe,
and we got,
we got to read this one again,
Joel,
like it's the,
it's the first time we want to want to move beyond.
I have to do this because this guy wants to,
let's do this and then and then we got to eat something.
Dude,
I'm going to pass the fuck out.
You know?
Why don't you just go shave your legs and get it done with you.
Fucking don't even pussy.
All right.
You wonder.
This is the answer.
We'll give them them a little taste of uninformed.
Just imagine if we were talking about global warming and it was,
sounded this ignorant.
That is the uninformed show that's worth a fucking dollar,
isn't it?
It is.
God Damn Jesus hard.
It's hard to shine this.
Never Watch the Beatles.
They used to get chased down the street by their fans.
Now it's gone full circle.
We're chasing fans,
pleading with them to,
to give us a fucking measly dollar for our art.
I like how [inaudible] I'm actually acting like they refuse to do it without
them even saying it.
I'm okay bill.
First off,
I'm a huge fan.
I love the podcast.
I have a bit of a dilemma.
I'm 35 years old.
I have a 30 year old sister and I'm very protective of her.
She has a,
that I used to be very tight with.
Um,
a few weeks ago we were coming back back from the cubs game,
even though the cock suckers last,
the three of us,
we had a blast at that game,
but we were all kind of lit.
How many fucking nights have started this way?
Everybody's having a good time,
but you get a little drunk,
Joe.
Yeah.
Well let's try a nice,
nice fucking game.
Those fucking gets fucking fucking game.
All right.
We're all kind of lit and on the way back I was sitting in the back seat of his
car while he was driving.
Um,
I was doing that flick the ear thing and he was starting to get pissed.
So he's flicking this kid in the back of his ear as he's trying to drunk drive
down the street after their home team lost.
Okay?
That's how this story is beginning.
He goes,
I should've quit,
but I was buzzed.
Long story short,
we were at a light and I flicked him and then this cunt sucker,
he invented a curse word.
This cunt sucker punched me in the face,
knocked my tooth loose and I had to pull it out later.
All right.
First of all,
how hard did he flick them in the,
that's one of those things where you would try and to flick the year and then
you caught the whole fucking ear in his ear was probably ringing.
So anyways,
he had to pull his tooth out later.
So he says,
after he cracked me,
I got out of the car and tried to pull him through his window in the middle of
traffic.
Um,
he locked the doors and rolled up his window.
My sister was started going nuts on me to get back in the car.
I didn't,
I don't claim to be a hard ass,
but I got to get my do.
I'm fucking losing sleep over this shit.
How do I explain to my sis that this shit has to be done without sounding like a
caveman?
He's been ducking me,
sent to census.
Shit happen.
He's got to catch a beating and uh,
he will,
I just need to explain to my sis why this shit had to be done.
So basically his quote,
his,
his question is he stating that because even though he's flicking this kid in
the year,
the dude knocked his tooth out.
Okay.
He did it in front of his sister.
He's like,
this kid has to catch a beating is just some guy on guy guys understand this
shit.
How do I explain it to my sister?
So she doesn't think she can move beyond.
You're beating the shit out of my boyfriend.
Well,
I'm going to say this dude,
you're fucking,
we actually talked about,
why don't we just get catched cut to the church.
You're five years older that your youngest sister,
you're protective of her.
You know,
you don't like the fact you wanted her to remain a virgin her entire fucking
life.
But you knew in the back of your head that eventually a guy was going to be
coming along.
And as Nice as this guy is,
and even though you get along with them in the back of your head,
you can't get past the fact that this guy's fucking your sister.
You know he's fucking your sister and there's nothing you can do about it.
So every once in a while when you get drunk,
that fucking hatred comes out in you and you start to be a little bit of a cunt
and you took it a little too far.
He was drunk.
You know,
Joe,
is there anything more annoying than somebody whacking you in the back of the
head is you're driving.
Okay.
He lost his shit.
He blasted you in the face.
You F you fucking,
you deserve to do exactly.
What would you do if he was doing it to you?
Yeah,
you'd clock him in his fucking face and you deal with it.
That losing your tooth,
his payment for becoming an adult.
That's what that is.
You're not losing sleep because you want to get this guy back.
You're losing sleep because you know you act like a fucking asshole and you got
JC on go easy.
You got you.
Got You.
But it's it just because this is,
cause I also understand dude,
if some,
if I was looking somebody in the year and I lost my fucking Tutu,
I would want to kill the guy.
Don't put your hands on somebody now.
You don't put your hands on somebody,
man.
You just don't do that.
You put your hands with somebody,
you get what you deserve.
That's it.
You don't touch.
All right,
show.
What if for some reason you were doing something,
you will flicking me in the back or whatever.
I don't know what the fuck.
And I turn around and I punched you in the face.
This guy gave mornings.
Tell him,
stop.
If you should stop doing it,
dude,
I would've stopped.
All right Joe.
Well,
let's see.
Let's,
let's do something here.
Okay,
I'm just being deviled at devil's advocate.
What would you rather have somebody flick your ears 17 times or lose a tooth?
Be Honest.
Of course.
Flick my ear of corn,
right?
So what happened was,
what was this kid supposed to do?
They'll turn around and try to flick his ear back.
No,
he did.
He did the right thing.
You go stop the kids not stopping.
He clocks him.
Finally,
Dude.
So what does he do?
So what?
What does he do?
What is,
what is his,
how does nothing?
He actually got mad.
This guy can't sleep,
Joe.
He goes,
you gotta help him.
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you how you get sleep again.
Grow Up.
Be a man.
Go to the guy.
Why did I invite you on this?
Go to the guy because you agree with it.
You know what?
No,
not on a business thing,
Joe,
you know,
you know what?
You're a guest on this show.
I know my listeners look at this guy.
This guy's trying to justify beating the shit out of it.
Let me tell you,
this is what you got to do,
Dude.
This is how you got to get them back in a silly way.
I hate to say this,
but what you're doing here,
dude,
is you're going to beat the shit out of that guy.
Okay?
And it's going to get ugly because you already feel like you have to do as much
damn equal damage.
Who's what?
You have to knock a fucking tooth of his out.
And not only that,
you're,
you're laying there awake stewing about this shit.
It's going to get,
it's going to be brutal.
You're going to beat the shit out of him and she's going to be screaming like
Sharon Stone in fucking casino when James Woods is getting the shit kicked out
of him.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's gonna fuck up the holidays for years and if she ends up marrying,
this guy is going to be questions about whether you're going to be invited to
the,
to the,
to the wedding.
I totally understand why you're envisioning giving this guy an uppercut where
all of his teeth climbing together and they just crack like in a fucking
cartoon.
You are not wrong for wanting to do that,
but you can't,
you cannot do that.
So,
um,
you gotta you gotta think of some sort of practical joke.
Like you got to say like,
look,
you gotta be a man and be like,
I got out of line,
you knocked my tooth out and then this is what you could just to psychological
torture.
Just say,
I'm not going to beat the shit out of you,
but no,
I am going to get you back.
So the years you're going to take off of his life while he's waiting you to do
whatever the fuck you're going to do and don't damage his property.
I'm trying to think of something like,
I saw a guy in the Internet,
I saw a guy on the internet.
What I'm,
it's bad advice.
I'm telling you,
dude.
Well,
first of all,
this is all bad advice.
They shouldn't take any of our advice.
[inaudible] what he should do is demand thing to do here is go up to the guy and
go,
look,
dude,
I'm a little person.
And you say it like you're missing a tooth.
And I have a speech impediment to say it that way.
Look,
dude,
I,
man,
I lost my tooth,
but I was looking in the ear.
Look for Bari.
We're both thinking,
I'm sorry because dude,
you got to understand too.
The guy driving,
he sheds at the beginning of the letter,
they were all drunk.
This guy's drunk drive.
He's trying to kick and this guy's flicking him in the fucking head.
That's annoying enough.
You know what,
y'all,
I got to go with this.
You're right.
You know what,
dude?
You're being an asshole and you lost a tooth and you fucking embarrassed.
You got to look inward.
You're right,
Joe.
You know what?
You're right and fucking right.
He's keys.
Got It.
He's got to like,
dude,
you know you got to,
you're not learning the lesson here.
You're not learning the lesson.
What you're doing is you,
you're,
you're escalating.
You're absolutely right.
But listen,
I,
I gotta tell this because people say,
you know,
you've got to watch out when you give advice because you've got to know that
we're both a couple of fucking morons.
You know neither one of us has any,
we have no business giving out advice,
but you guys don't have the money during this economy to actually go to someone
who is smart.
So I understand why you're asking me this,
but don't take my advice ever on this podcast.
All right,
this is how I do it and I'm doing this for free.
What are you gonna assume me for?
Huh?
My fucking mixer.
You're not mentioning names,
you don't mention names.
So there's anonymity here and you're,
you're,
what you're telling the guy to do is nothing.
This is great.
Joe.
First of all,
do you understand what just happened here?
We went from being complete non psychologists,
non therapist,
non fucking educated people here giving advice to then now Joe seamlessly.
You went from that to then giving me legal advice.
Do you realize you just did that?
Nope,
of course you did.
That's right.
I just talk.
I say what?
I need this right,
and you'd deliver it with confidence and people believe it.
You know?
I realize what this advice,
people don't even want advice.
You know what they want.
They want to be encouraged,
but yes.
You know why Joe?
Because they're surrounded by a bunch of fucking cons.
I'm telling you,
it's not the al Qaeda,
it's not global warming.
It's the overwhelming amount of constant.
I tell you that.
I can't,
I can't tell this story.
I can't tell it,
but,
and I brought it up.
I gotta to change the city.
I got to change.
Okay.
Let's say this happened fucking nine and a half weeks ago now.
That's she.
I got you.
I'll blog,
but it's not fair to bring up a story and leave these fucking people hanging
here.
I'll just,
I'll give you the gist of it.
I'm fucking,
I got into a political debate with somebody.
Okay.
Who clearly I,
I,
I do,
you know,
I don't mind debating with people and I can be swayed.
Look,
I got swayed in that fucking argument.
Made a great guy,
Dan Point.
I was a moron and you know,
sometimes I stick to my guns with the pancake thing.
You know,
I'm not a perfect person Joe.
Is that the beginning?
An awful song.
I'm not a perfect person.
Yeah.
So why don't you just stop that in itself.
There are,
that's just one of those sides.
Just makes you want to punch every girl in the bar in the face.
Cause they all start singing it.
Sometimes I stick to my guns.
I didn't want you sing it,
but wait a minute,
this is what happened.
Somebody we got in this political debate and this person was making
moronic points just like I was,
but I was,
but I was delivering my moronic points in a car like in a courtesy way and a
respectful way.
Right.
I'd be like,
you know,
we're talking about,
Iraq kind of fucked he,
I go,
the only successful,
you know,
occupation I've ever seen has been this country and it's because we weren't
leaving and we committed genocide.
So how do,
how do you win over there?
I don't,
I don't get it.
Did we just,
you know,
guys who just getting picked off over there and it's pissing me off.
Right.
So she would make points on how we could win over there and then she,
and when,
after she was done making her points,
you go,
uh,
Duh.
Right?
Do you realize the arrogant level of that?
Like I do.
She's acting like,
for some reason the fucking super genius generals of our own fucking army of
this country.
They can't seem how to fucking finish yet,
but this girl knows how to do it in the middle of nowhere,
having never fought a war and to,
she kept sticking her head out,
gone a Duh.
Yeah,
she's doing,
she's doing the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the couch coach.
Yeah.
No,
she wasn't eating with this guy.
And let's see,
this is somebody who clearly,
you know,
you can tell somebody they reek of not traveling,
that fucking their worldview from their culdesac is fucking,
you know,
and if they and will gives a shit mean I'm acting like I'm a fucking genius.
I'm not,
but,
but at least I have the presence of mind to know that I'm a fucking moron,
so I will,
you know who I was arguing with that pancake shit I knew in the back of the head
I was probably wrong on stuff,
which is why I made it funny.
I would never be like,
Joe,
there's no sprinkles on pancakes.
A duh stick.
Do you know what?
Are you able to punch me in the face and I'd lose a tooth.
Right.
Look at me and saying false.
And that's our out.
That's how out for that.
That's how it happens though.
Don't you do that?
Don't you mock how I just got out of that?
No,
I was show you Daniel.
Oh,
you didn't know I was saying.
There you go.
I'll say did to get a sandwich of starving joke.
Wait,
where did you get your basketball shorts?
I don't know.
Somebody gave them to me.
I know you don't play this.
I don't like how shiny they are.
Like you were an all star one year,
like your gym.
Like I'm,
I don't like them.
I just put them on because I don't care if I shit them up while I'm doing the
laundry.
Doing the with the laundry.
All right,
listen,
that's a,
there you go.
There's our first,
our first fucking guest ever.
Joe De Rosa and Joe de Rosa and classic spirit of our wonderful radio show.
The uninformed show has now informed me that there is no difference between
pancakes and donuts.
He gave me legal advice,
anonymity.
We talked sports today.
Thanks for having me on,
man.
It's fun.
Okay,
well I tell you,
I really enjoy doing shows with you and I really hope that people,
when we finally get these fucking episodes up,
which I will let you know on the,
uh,
on the,
on the podcast here,
cause this thing I just do is a goof or whatever as opposed to the uninformed
thing,
which is so fucking serious.
Um,
I'll let you know when it's up cause uh,
we really,
seriously,
man,
that's something that,
you know,
as much as my stand up,
I want to build that radio show because I got to met man.
I think it's just as good as anything else that's out there and God got,
dammit.
It's worth a dollar to take a risk.
And if like usual,
I don't have any information of when it's going to be up,
but hopefully by next week,
Joe,
can you find some fucking tech nerve train up there?
I'm trying.
Trying a dude.
That's not what your outfit says.
You're off.
That says I quit.
All right,
let's go get some pancakes.
You'll get a doughnut.
All right.
Thanks for listening to the uninformed.
I mean,
not on a form.
I'm sorry to the,
to the Monday morning podcast.
Why saw your cute face?
I thought that's what we were doing.
You guys all have a good week.
Hey,
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the Improv in Pittsburgh this weekend.
I'm at the top of my game.
Motherfuckers,
I've been on the road for the last five weeks.
Okay.
So you fucking strap in and put on your comedy hats and take that wet whistle
between your fucking toes.
Cause I'm bringing the comedy.
What am I hyping
Joe?
This is my podcast.
You're selfish cunt.
All right.
When are you going to be there?
The weekend of October 23rd on the 23rd and 24th I'll be recording my CD at the
stress factory for comedy central records.
Stress Factor,
New Brunswick,
New Jersey.
Please come out please.
23rd 24th of October.
And I'll tell you this,
Joe.
I will argue they have the best Mozzarella sticks of any comedy club.
Dude,
it's the perfect combination where the,
where the outer layer is nice and crunchy.
And you know,
I hate the ones that,
it's just all mush.
It's just like you're eating like garlic bread that somebody dropped in a fry
later.
So even if you don't like Joe's act,
you can sit there now.
Go check them out.
I,
I a,
I backed Joe.
Joe Rose's a funny motherfucker.
All right,
you guys all wasn't that sweet.
everybody a
wait,
ticketing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].